i'm very excited to introduce to you
today dr
joel wallick because what you're about
to hear in the next 120 minutes or so
is nothing short of amazing our health
is one of the most valuable things we
have
we all want to be healthy and happy yet
with so much information
out there how do you know who to listen
to how do you know who's telling the
truth when it comes to getting well
dr wallach has degrees in agriculture
and veterinary science
and has been a physician for over 35
years he was in charge of a monumental
study that did over twenty thousand
autopsies on animals and humans
and ten million blood chemistries he's
written fourteen books
he's been published seventy times all
over the world he was a nobel prize
nominee
he sold over 180 million copies of his
book and cd
dead doctors don't lie and he's had to
sue the fda
eight times for the right to make
certain health claims that are true
when he couldn't get doctors to take
note of the fact that the animal
industry
eliminated almost every birth defect in
over 900 diseases and animals with
simple nutritional formulas
and that it should work the same way in
humans he became a physician himself
his work is now changing the lives of
millions of individuals around the world
if i told you that almost all chronic
diseases such as
type 2 diabetes high blood pressure
heart disease arthritis fibromyalgia
obesity ms migraines eczema psoriasis
and almost everything else you can think
of was the result of nutritional
deficiencies
and that you could make them go away one
hundred percent would that be of
interest to you and your loved ones
if so the things you're going to hear in
the next two hours have the power to
change your life forever
without anything further let's turn
things over to dr wallach
appreciate the introduction um
all right i'm just gonna start out just
a quick reminder the thing that makes my
view different
is that i have a degree in agriculture
and in agriculture we don't have
health insurance for animals like we do
people
and so we just had to get rid of the
diseases and
agriculture we have veterinarians who
would take care of animals and if he
didn't fix it the first time out to the
farm the farmer never called you back
in human medicine they treat you for 25
30 years
because you have insurance insurance has
been the worst possible thing for human
health
because it allowed doctors to use you
for an atm machine
even though their cure is available they
will treat you for 25 years even though
there's cures available
there's no law requiring them to carry
there's a cure available okay that's a
huge problem
as you're all finding out now but you're
going to learn some things
today that will help you take care of
yourself and the people you love
and of course i also have a degree in
veterinary medicine i'm a veterinarian
i also have a degree compared to
pathologists i do autopsies on animals
and people
i also have a degree as a physician
naturopathic physician i'm a primary
care physician
in oregon licensed in oregon and
california for 35 years and what i do
differently from
other doctors is i treat people like
dogs but they get better
because in the dogs we've learned how to
eliminate 900 different diseases in dogs
that still plague people
we've learned how to triple the lifespan
of dogs we didn't do that with
organ transplants and stem cells and
genetically injured proteins and wonder
drugs we did simply
putting vitamins minerals or canned dog
for their bags of dried dog food
and then we eliminate every birth defect
you can name and ten times that many
can't name eliminate all those birth
defects
just by putting vitamins minerals in
your food there's not a single birth
defect you can name
this genetically transmitted although
doctors would tell you they are but
there's not a single genetically
transmitted birth defect they're all
nutritional deficiencies the embryo okay
let's get to work here we're going to
divide this into two pieces
number one i'm going to show you what
the problem is and then number two
i'm going to show you how to eliminate
these disease okay
well americans spend more money we've
been doing this since the second world
war we spend more money for healthcare
than all the nations the world combined
not more than any nation more than all
nations
there's 204 nations in the united
and we spend more money each year for
health care than all of them combined we
spend just short of three trillion
dollars for health care what do we get
for it we're 92nd and healthiness
there's 91 other nations
whose peoples are healthier than us
according to our cdc the center for sea
control of atlanta georgia
we rank 60th in longevity there's 59
other nations whose peoples live longer
than us
and god forgive us we rank 41st in live
birth and first month survivability of
our babies
december 2008 time magazine cover
article says the annual checkup of
american health
oops the sorry state of american health
remember we're spending more money for
health care
than all the nations of the world
combined and the only thing they can say
on the cover
of time magazine in december of 2008
about our health care
is the sorry state of american health
despite technological advances in
medicine americans are less healthy than
we used to be our
health is declining okay it's getting
worse
more doctors more pharmaceuticals more
insurance more of everything
and it's getting worse worse yet is the
next generation your kids are going to
be worse off
experts in medical schools tell us
that our children are not going to live
as long as us if things continue to go
the way they're going
they're not saying that you're going to
die at 75 and your kids are going to die
at 72
15 years from now what they're saying is
you are going to be burying your
children you'll be staying at your
gravesite bearing your children
if you don't change what's going on here
the doctors aren't going to change
the pharmaceutical industry is not going
to change we're going to have to do it
now the most important part of a human
being's life in the first 91 days of
pregnancy that's when the embryo
after fertilization the egg is
fertilized by the sperm the embryo goes
down this assembly line 91 days
it's assembled after that the rest of
the six months of pregnancy is just
building size it's like a car going down
the assembly line
let's say the car is going down the
assembly let's say it's a rolls-royce i
mean we're talking about a quarter of a
million dollar car or a half a million
dollar car
when it gets to the point where the fuel
pump is supposed to be installed there's
no fuel pumps here but the car keeps
going down the assembly line
and then there's a place where the
headlights are not supposed to be there
it keeps going down the assembly line
comes off the line
the car will crank but it won't start
because there's no fuel getting to it
can't drive at night because there's no
lights
that's what happens call them birth
defects there's not a single birth
defect that's genetic all birth defects
are in fact preventable we've done in
the animal industry
so let's look at some of this stuff
because i don't think i was giving you
false figures
when it comes to live births and and
first month survivability
of our babies we're number 41 in the
world it says the usa shame that is not
true
that is not true because you put up
money you you spend more money for
health care than all the other nation
world combined so it's not america's
shame
is the ob gyn shame if every ob
gyn was put in jail for six months every
time they had a baby bar with a birth
defect
in the pregnancy that they monitored
after a couple years it wasn't many more
babies born with birth defects because
they'd learned what i'm going to teach
you tonight
so pay attention here okay now whether
you agree with sarah palin's
politics or not she's a very powerful
woman she is a governor of alaska
she was the vice presidential candidate
for this united states for a large
party political party and her ob gyn
who monitored her pregnancy allowed her
pregnancy to result in a very i'm sure
very nice child
but with down syndrome trisomy 21 down
syndrome is not a genetically
transmitted disease it's a simple
nutritional deficiency in the first 10
minutes of pregnancy when a woman misses
two periods and then she goes on
prenatal vitamins it's two months too
late
the first 10 minutes of pregnancy if you
don't have everything that baby needs
one out of 700 babies out of the
millions of babies that are born every
year in america one out of 700
babies in this country are born with
down syndrome somebody needs to go to
jail here folks
totally unnecessary i've ever heard of
cerebral palsy
there's a cerebellum little part of the
brain that controls your fine motor
movement so you can play the piano and
stand on one foot and balance yourself
and all those kind of stuff it's called
the cerebellum
and when a baby's born it's about the
size of a tangerine if it's normal
but babies with cerebral palsy their
cerebellum is the size of a grape
not genetic it's just when it was babies
going down the assembly line
the stuff that was necessary to make
that cerebellum wasn't there and it
could be a size of a grape it could be
half the size of a tangerine three
quarters of the size of a tangerine
extremely minor cerebral palsy they're
somewhat modest some
modestly severe and some severe and then
there's some catastrophic like this
young lady
totally preventable you see the embryo
starts out as a disc and then it falls
into a tube
and all this stuff going on if the
things aren't there
when it's supposed to be you get these
defects and who should we blame should
we blame ourselves
is america's shame no no no it's the ob
gyns how much nutrition do they get
zero in eight years of medical school
they get zero nutrition
and what is the most important thing in
the life of an embryo nutrition
somebody needs to go to jail and then
talk about all these cleft lip cleft
palates these are all simple nutritional
deficiencies of the embryo
when the baby is a flat disc it folds up
it doesn't fold up all at once it's kind
of like a zipper
this is folding so it starts out at the
top and goes on down to the bottom
and you get belly button hernias you get
things like hiatal hernias in the
diaphragm
and you can find a good christian
surgeon who will donate his time to sew
these little kids up
it'll cost you 250 dollars that save the
children
to for each kid for the anesthesia and
the suture material to swim up so i can
suck on a straw and speak intelligibly
they're not going to look
beautiful like movie stars because
they're still going to have massive
scars and things
but these things are totally preventable
so now you're armed now you're dangerous
because you know
something and so when do you start a
child
with all 90 essential nutrients all 90
essential vitamins minerals well before
they're conceived
before they're conceived all through the
pregnancy that they're
developed in from the moment they're
born and after one generation we will
never have a child with any birth defect
now how many heard of genetics dna you
know that double helix all that kind of
stuff the double helix in the dna
um was identified in 1953 by james
watson an american and francis crick
a englishman and they were running up
and down we found it
we we know the secret of life now if you
have a genetic disease like diabetes
we can engineer in a test tube a normal
gene from you we can take a stem cell
for you
we'll engineer a perfectly normal gene
for diabetes and we'll replace your
diabetes genes with it and we'll get rid
of your disease
i mean they were excited nine years
later they actually got the nobel prize
for it
for mapping out this double helix
structure and i mean
science went to work they came up with
genetics tests 850 genetics tests right
this is december 2012 cover article time
magazine
i just love it the time magazine knows
more than the medical trade they don't
know their anatomy though
they say this baby is colon cancer gene
is in his right shoulder
his glaucoma gene for blindness in the
eye is due is in his right knee
and his prostate cancer gene is in his
left knee well
guess what to have all these tests we
spent
one trillion dollars that's a thousand
billion dollars we've spent
mapping out the human genome how many
know in 2001 we did it we've mapped out
the human genome we know all the
sequence of all the things now
right that was uh 12 years ago
now to the date when they got their
nobel p when they discovered it in 1953
watson and crick
watson 60 years to the date march 22
2013 says he was speaking to the
university of california san diego and
the
sauk institute and he said gene sequence
is not the solution
to solving diseases the solution is good
chemistry means vitamins minerals
gene sequencing to cure cancer and
diabetes and obesity and hybrid pressure
and all this kind of stuff
is irrelevant everything they've done
the last 60 years of genetics
the guy who got the nobel prize for it
says it's irrelevant
now i said that in 1978 and they all
laughed at me of course most of them
laughed at me are all dead
but watson said you can sequence 150 000
people a day you're not gonna cure
cancer diabetes or any other disease
most of the experiments we've done over
the last six years have been irrelevant
because none of it's genetic
so i have a book coming out at the end
of this year it's my 14th book
this is the cover of it epigenetics the
death of the genetic theory of disease
transmission
all the diseases that are said to be
genetic are in here and shows you how to
prevent them and how to reverse them
okay now here it comes now be alert for
this one
this is it now there's a very boring
scientific journal called food chemistry
you pick that thing up and you open up
it's just page after page of columns of
numbers and things
and just like carrot and numbers and
beats and numbers and corn and numbers
what they do they send teams of graduate
students out
to farms and they personally harvest
some carrots and beets and corn and
wheat and
tomatoes and beans and peas and then
they run them to the lab and they
find out what nutrition's in them and
they find out what pollution is in them
then they follow that farmer's
harvest to the stores and they rerun it
again for nutrition and pollution see
what pollution was added to it during
the
processing and getting there and how
much nutrition was lost
during the packaging and shipping and
reon packaging and putting on the store
well in april 2012 april 16 this issue
said commercial available baby foods
they looked at eight of them were
talking about gerber
similac infamil very trusted names in
america
okay commercial available baby foods may
contain less than twenty percent
of the recommended levels of many
minerals and vitamins less than twenty
percent
dog food has a hundred percent
laboratory rat food has a hundred
percent
laboratory rabbit food has a hundred
percent chicken sheep pig horse cow food
has a hundred percent
and your babies and grandbabies have
less than twenty percent why is that
because of medical trade
and eight years of medical school gets
no nutrition they just train them how to
take your credit card and how to
prescribe prescriptions
that's it this is the cause of most of
our problems right here
and so now i'm going to tell you
remember i have a degree in agriculture
i'm a veterinarian
i'm a compared pathologist one project
for national institutes of health at
emory university
i did over 20 000 autopsies 20 million
chemistries
is published in a 1200 page book that's
in the smithsonian institute as a
national treasure
i then went on became a physician
because i couldn't get doctors do what i
was saying to do so i went and did it
myself
sometimes you just got to do it and so
that's where i come from
well in veterinary industry we
eliminated 900 different diseases still
plagued people
not with wonder drugs and stem cells and
organ transplants and gently injured
proteins we did it simply by putting
vitamins and minerals in our dog food to
eliminate every birth defect you can
name in 10 times that many you can't
just simply by putting vitamins minerals
under dog food we've tripled their
lifespan
six years ago an old dog was eight years
old today old dog is 25.
we do that simply by putting vitamins
and minerals in their dog food and so i
decided to treat people like dogs
and you know what they got better
newsweek magazine
cover story and as most people's
initially actually get a little giggle
out of this kid he thinks he's won the
lottery
he's clutching this nice warm envelope
full of super-sized french fries
he is one happy kid right but he's
doomed
he says when i grow up i'm gonna weigh
300 pounds help
it's not genetic it's actually a simple
nutritional deficiency disease i don't
know
how many of you know this but i actually
wrote a book as i don't know
19 early 2004 or something like that
called hell's kitchen it was actually
based on a sermon that i gave my own
church
in san diego and the pastor gave me
permission we have a cd of it
and i said pastor i want to call it
hell's kitchen he thought for me he said
well hell yeah
so i thought he was cool and so he sell
millions of that little cd in the book
hell's kitchen goes into all the proof
that obesity
is a simple nutritional deficient
disease now how many of you know that
we're the number one obese nation in the
world
we spend more money for health care than
all the nations of the world combined
and the only thing we can brag about
being number one in the area of health
is we're the most obese nation in the
world
and so what does that tell you about
what the medical system knows about
obesity
veterinarians know everything about it i
can make prime beef
i can make beef with no fat on it so i
use the same principles right
1978 i started it's a simple nutritional
deficiency we do this thousands of times
a day now we get people lose 140 pounds
in 100 days we get people to lose 90
pounds
uh in 75 days we have thousands of
people every day to lose 50 pounds
in a couple months very simple stuff
once you know what button to push it's
easy
now here comes the beauty of this whole
thing
june 20th 2013 the ama declared obesity
disease well
hallelujah see prior to that time
they said obesity is just people making
bad choices in food and lack of exercise
and too much screen time and all that
kind of stuff
no it's a simple nutritional deficiency
i'm going to prove that to you here in a
minute
say simple you take the nutrients it
just goes away it's real simple
now i guarantee you they didn't do this
out of the goodness of their heart that
they declared a disease
and here's why i say this the medical
system
because of this this new healthcare
thing coming on
is hurting particularly specialist
medicare
when the doctor bills medicare for 100
bucks medicare only pays them 20.
so the primary care physicians the
family doctors aren't referring patients
out anymore you know
a primary care physician can do a hip
replacement operation
there's no law that says he can't a
primary care physician can write
prescriptions for radiology to do heart
tests and he can then prescribe you the
same drugs that a specialist would
and so suddenly now the family doctors
are keeping
the the complicated patients because
medicare is not paying much anymore
so the specialists are starving they're
looking around
they're selling their businesses to
hospitals hospitals are tripling the
prices of tests
and prosthesis and surgeries and and
procedures and drugs
because they have no competition on the
field anymore so they just triple the
price once they bought up the last
doctor practice in town they just triple
the price they have no competitors
anymore
that lovely now so why then did doctors
declare obesity disease
because insurance pays for diseases
they say well where where all the fish
at well the fish are in obesity
and so we'll declare disease now so
insurance will pay for it now we can
make our house payment that's why they
did it it's not because of the goodness
of their heart
have you heard add adhd and autism it
has nothing to do with vaccinations
those things have anything to do with
vaccinations i'm a pathologist so i do
crazy things i i looked at batch numbers
that nobody else did before
i look at bash numbers on vaccinations
there's only a you know less than a
dozen
manufacturers of childhood vaccinations
and then they re
they private label them all the
distribution companies and everything
use the same raw materials they have the
same batch numbers no matter what whose
labels are they use the same batch
numbers
and they use the same batch numbers in
africa and asia and europe and north
america and central america and south
america but 95
of all autism and adhd 95 percent is in
this country
so it's not the vaccinations let's see
remember food chemistry april 16
2012 our babies are getting less than 20
percent of the nutrients they require
your brain requires nutrients you're
getting less i mean there's no nutrition
and fruity pebbles and apple juice
there's no nutrition sugar frosted
flakes and welch's grape juice
there's no nutrition in eggos or
instant oatmeal and sunny delight
that's why we have all these problems
these kids because their brains are
dying of malnutrition
not vaccinations how many hurt
alzheimer's disease raise your hand
this article came out obviously february
of this year said
alzheimer's patients could triple by
2050 well i guarantee they are
because there's 80 million baby boomers
come along who are reaching that age are
over
65 now and so there's 80 million of them
that's one-third of our population
so they're going to triple i mean that's
just sheer simple fourth grade math it's
not a big deal right
uh doctors say help us we need to
find something to help us keep the
number of alzheimer's patients down to
13.8 million a year
i want to show you how to eliminate it
because it's a physician-caused disease
alzheimer's disease did not exist in any
way shape or form in 1942
today is the number four killer of
adults over the age of 65.
look at who owns all the hospices
medical doctors
now here comes the medical doctors i
thought politicians were bad but medical
doctors the only people who can say
three lies in the same sentence
alzheimer's is the only disease amongst
the top six killers in the usa for which
there's no prevention care or treatment
that none of those three are true
doctors are so terrible when it comes to
dementia if you reach the age of 65 one
in three of americans who reach age 65
will die from dementia
they suck when it comes to this my
grandkids would say
now why do our kids die before we do
well right now there's more kids under
the age of 18
dying of stroke in america than people
over the age of 65.
that's because stroke is not genetic
stroke is not an accidental thing or
just some dumb thing happening
i actually see the fda over this and i
have prevailed but doctors don't pay
attention
to those sorts of things they keep doing
what they do right
so what causes stroke it's a deficiency
of
or a ratio problem between omega three
sixes and nine i actually see the fda
over this
to be able to say you can supplement
with omega-3s and
actually reduce and eliminate
thrombotic stroke blood clots in the
brain coronary thrombosis pulmonary
embolism and deep vein thrombosis
before i sued the fda and federal court
and prevailed with my own money no
no we didn't have any organization it
was my money
because i couldn't stand it anymore so
you see there's no omega-3s and cheerios
or oatmeal
or sunny delight you only say before i
sued them you can only say
eating foods rich in omega-3s could
reduce the risk of thrombotic stroke and
kernel thrombosis
i had to sue them to be able to say like
i'm telling you tonight you can
supplement properly
and guarantee you're never going to have
that problem okay now i'm 74 years old
i've never been to a doctor in the last
65 years
never been on a prescription medication
i don't have any health problems
nobody's going to steal an airplane with
me on it
i find it amusing that they'll take your
fingernail clipper away from you and i
can kill three people in a minute with
my ballpoint pen
government is typically stupid right
aarp american associates retired people
they're marketing to 55 year olds now i
love that
okay march 2012 a little over a year ago
cover article
the worst place to be in america when
you're sick is american hospital i took
two pieces out of the article and says
the number of american patients who die
each year from american hospital air is
equal to four jumbo jets crashing each
week save
fifteen hundred people three thousand
every two weeks six thousand a month
seventy two thousand a year
if you knew that commercial airlines
killed 72 000 passengers a year how many
of you would fly
nobody would fly i got to go see my
doctor i got to go see my doctor i got
to go see my doctor
okay then it also said in that article
each u.s surgeon operates on the wrong
person wrong body part as often as 40
times a week
even a three-year-old knows left from
right that was in march
in december of 2012 each surge in the
united states makes thousands of errors
they get a walk now why is that 1914
almost exactly 100 years ago
medical doctors legislated themselves
into a protected monopoly
there was a thing called the flexion
report back in 1914.
they legislated themselves into a
protected monopoly
they're the only legal monopoly in
america they legislated not only did
they legislate themselves into being a
monopoly but they legislated all their
competition into being quacks
if you're not an md you're a quack the
federal government the state government
the county and city only recognizes mds
the
military only recognizes mds yet they
have failed us terribly
ranked 92nd in the world in healthiness
we rank 60th longevity
and we rank 41st libraries and and first
one survivability were babies
there's no competition you see i can't
go
to a public meeting and say you don't
have to take
drugs for diabetes for 30 years and go
blind get your legs cut off and
have 25 years of your life go away and
gain too much weight and all those kind
of stuff
with a little simple nutritional program
which we call a healthy blood sugar pack
you know there's over 100 billion
dollars worth of research into that
healthy
blood sugar pack sounds pretty simple
healthy pleasure back there's 100
billion dollars worth of research in
that
we've known for 70 years it's a simple
mineral deficiency disease
you take this within four to six weeks
you'll be off your medication you'll be
an ex-diabetic
is that simple newsweek magazine cover
article
august 2011. the one word that will save
your life in a hospital it's a
two-letter word that every two-year-old
knows
no okay we've given you six rounds of
chemotherapy now you have three minutes
to live
we want to try this new experimental
drug on you that's because the fda
requires
them to tell them how many people out of
every 100 they give the drug to how many
are killed by the drug
they're using you as a guinea pig when
they say you've only got weeks to live
and we want to try this new experimental
drug on yes to find out if it kills you
or not
and so you should say no wouldn't you
rather the last two weeks of your life
would rather be in your own bed with
your dog on your lap hugging your
grandkids
instead of when your grandkid comes to
the hospital because everybody knows you
only have days or weeks to live
and the nurse says i'm sorry honey you
can't go in to see your grandma now
she's being killed by the doctor
that's what it translates to you can't
see your you can't see your grandma now
she's intensive care
what kind of nonsense is that stop
taking them to
hospice hospice nurses will come to your
home
do hospice at home don't give those
doctors
every last penny the family has that's
the centerfold from that issue in
newsweek magazine
what is he afraid of this is a universal
fear posture right no matter what
language you speak no matter what color
you are that this is a fear posture
whether it's spaceman or
godzilla or whatever right and so what
is he afraid of well i'll tell you
there's seven doctors on the opposing
page coming to him i want you to look at
them and see if they're coming to them
him with a good christian heart they
look like
a scene from the night of the walking
dead tv series
that's because he's the only one in the
hospital with money
they're all after him everybody else in
the hospital is a medicare patient and
they don't want them they'll kill each
other
trying to get to him reader's digest
very warm fuzzy magazine you find it in
all professional
waiting rooms whether an attorney or an
architect or a doctor a veterinarian a
dentist everybody has
reader's digest you don't even need to
read it you know there'll be warm fuzzy
stories
dog drags a two-year-old out of the
house during a fire
four-year-old calls saves grandma's life
that's the kind of stuff that you find
readers digest
well in june of 2007 possible mistakes
you can avoid
look at the font sizes blood red is
screaming at you to read this thing
do you think every doctor made sure this
issue was in their waiting room
i don't think so i spent 20 years in the
air force myself i love
veterans and this study came out it was
from the department of veterans affairs
did this study
it was a self-study okay and it came out
in december of 1997 and they published
to the public in 1999.
hundreds of thousands of mistakes each
year in the va system 3 000 which are
serious where they
take out the healthy lung they leave the
cancerous lung in you go in for a
hemorrhoid operation
and they take your cerebellum out of
your brain or something you know did
really
dumb stuff and and 3 000 those mistakes
are that serious
the person either dies in the hospital
or they
uh are required to stay another year
well look at what the
department of veterans affairs said
about 700 of these 3 000 major mistakes
they kill they kill 700.
you know how many american servicemen
and women were killed last year in
afghanistan 380.
medical doctors in the va system kill
more american service men and women
every year
than the enemy when do you get angry
enough
to do something about it okay we have to
do something and what what it's going to
take is for us to stop
going to them we have to take care of
our loved ones and take care of herself
last year we set a record and more
servicemen returning
kill themselves than the last 10 years
combined
that's because they live on mres
there's nothing more than a meal bar and
distilled water
no vitamins and minerals so if you have
anybody in the service
in your family or in your church you
need to be sending them the 90s
essential nutrients
they'll come home and be okay they're
out there carrying those 80 pound
packs they sweat they don't get any
nutrition
they sweat out all that nutrition this
is one of my favorite stories it came
out
february 2007 look at the title patient
protect themselves kind of vanilla
the data that we share with you came
from the generally american medical
association the most prestigious medical
journal america maybe the world
and the center for disease control again
that federal agency that tracks this
kind of stuff
in atlanta georgia and they said this
article said using those two agencies as
their source of information
it said each year in america each year
each year in america medical doctors
kill
injure and infect 15 million customers
at workplace
each and american medical doctors kill
injured infect 15 million customers in
the workplace
5.8 million households and 9.2 million
in the private office and clinics
now how many would fly commercial
airlines if you knew that they killed
injured and infected 15 million
passengers every year
nobody would fly so we went to war in
afghanistan
because the bad guys killed 3 000 new
yorkers
here's one group of tradesmen here in
this country yearly
kill injured in fact 15 million
got a few more of these and i think
you'll have the picture and then we'll
get to the diseases but i think you need
to know what the problem is
being a veterinarian and a physician
this is important to me this one
remember i said each in america
according to the center for disease
control which they also did this study
center disease control
of atlanta and the general american
medical association medical doctors each
year in their workplace kill
injured infect 15 million well in the
hospitals
remember this is just the hospitals this
does not include clinics in the hospital
there's 2 million infections each year
of those 2 million infections each year
90 000 die
okay now i'm going to show you if people
say that he's exaggerated what do i show
you this
you haven't seen the next slide yet now
how does that happen how can that happen
in a hospital supposed to be a refuge a
place of safety and
so anyway what happens is they wear the
same white coat the same pantyhose the
same trousers
the same shoes room to room to room
dragging snot peep poop blood pus
viruses bacteria fungus and yeast by
contrast in a pig barn by federal law
rent the spread of swine flu if you're a
visitor or a worker every morning when
you go into that barn
you have to take a shower with
disinfectant soap for like five minutes
you tear open a bag with a clean pair of
coveralls and boots
and before you go from one pig pen to
the next you're required to stand for
four minutes
in a four inch deep tub of disinfectant
and then brush your boots off with a
brush before you go to the next pig pen
we treat pigs in a barn better we treat
human beings in a hospital in this
country
okay this came out in august of 2012
about 10 months ago now
one bacteria c diff classroom difficult
which is a human poop bacteria that's
where it's only found in human poop
of those 90 000 deaths each year from
infections in the hospital thirty
thousand one-third of them
occur because doctors don't wash their
hands
in 1993 there were 85 700 of these c
diff infections reported in hospitals 30
000 which
result in death 17 years later 2010 it
went up 400
to 300 oh just started 350 346
800. does this chart give you some sense
that they're working hard to prevent the
problem no
there's no consequences why should they
wash their hands
if they're doing the right thing that
chart should look like that
this is what you're getting as your
hospitals folks
well let's look at pharmaceuticals well
everybody loves pharmaceuticals
i mean we have war on street drugs and
of course for the last 50 years
the pharmaceutical industry and the
medical doctors have been after the fda
to report adverse events
calls on herbs vitamins and minerals so
in 2007 they did it for the first time
reported in 2008
there were 600 adverse event calls of
course
these the pharmaceutical industry and
the medical doctors
assured the fda was going to be in the
thousands 400 adverse events
reports for herbs none of them were
fatalities they were like fast heart
rate from
too much green tea and you know mixture
or um they got
maybe itchy skin from something uh
200 of these were adverse events from
vitamins minerals somebody takes too
much vitamin c they get diarrhea
they take too much niacin vitamin b3
they get itchy rashy skin
no deaths well the same year in 2007
which they'd been doing for 50 years
they reported not to the public but in
the mortality and morbidity reports
which come out every week right
they reported it for the pharmaceuticals
prescription drugs
now it's in this report here but it's
very difficult to see it's down here in
the corner so i blew it up
because most people by the time they get
to here they're not going to read the
whole thing so they purposely put it
down here very tiny little thing
i blew it up so you can compare this 600
adverse events reports
non-fatalities with 482
154 adverse events reports for
prescription drugs that same year
all of these were fatalities you tell me
what's more dangerous pharmaceuticals
or vitamins and minerals but but but
it's fda approved
people always ask me are your vitamins
and minerals fda approved
i say drop your knees and give thanks
the lord they're not
because everything the fda approves
kills people every drug the fda approves
every drug
even baby aspirin has a little warning
on there one of the side effects may be
death
this is a yearly figure and this is
another look at the pharmaceutical thing
desperate medication air rising now
they're not talking about
the side effects of the drugs here
they're talking about decimal point
errors which i'm sure the pharmacists
thank god catch some of that stuff
when it comes in and then of course
doctors will prescribe three or four
different drugs of the same patient
particularly older people
um because insurance pays and they get a
kickback
right and so they do that and of course
you get potentiation and
that combination will kill the patient
these types of medication errors
each year are tied to 1.5 million
fatalities
and permanent injuries okay the only you
can stop this when the
doctor writes your prescriptions tear it
up from say sorry
okay this is the last one in this kind
of really bad series and we'll move on
to the next subject
this came out in 2010 hospital care
fatal for some
patients as kind of vanilla results
medicare study alarming well that's
alarming
the study was actually done by the us
department of health and human services
office
of inspector okay
so this study was done by the us
department of health and human services
office of inspector general which is the
auditor for medicare
okay what they said was that each month
not each year each month in america
medical doctors kill
15 000 medicare patients from simple
tests
and minors minor procedures they kill
fifteen thousand medicare patients
each month that's a hundred and eighty
thousand a year
if you're over age sixty five and you
knew the commercial
airlines killed 180 000 seniors over age
65 every year
you'd say honey cancel the airplane
flight i turned 65 yesterday we're going
amtrak
i'm going to show you three people three
people
very famous people who died as seniors
at the hands of doctors for minor
procedures
andy rooney 60 minutes retired at 92.
his wife is 87 they were going to go on
a world cruise for a year
and she was a little nervous she said
look we can't speak half those languages
the place we're going we need to take a
disc of our health care stuff in case we
get sick
or that age you know he said okay so
they go to the doctor and while they're
waiting for the disc to be cut
with all their medical records in it the
doctor is rooting through andy's
medical records he says andy you're 92
years old and i can't find you i've ever
had a colonoscopic exam you could have
cancer lurking around in you
i wasn't there of course but i could i
know andy rooney because he used to
watch him every sunday in 16 minutes i
just loved his sense of humor
and um i i can see him saying well i
don't have blood in my bowel movement i
haven't had to change my bowel habits in
the last 10 years
i haven't lost any weight i don't have
pelvic pain i don't think i have any
colon cancer that's what he should have
said but i'm sure the doctor insisted
and he should have said andy should have
said no
instead he said being a compliant 90s
year old he said oh okay
comes in the next day the doctor sticks
a garden hose up his rump punctures
intestine
three days later he's dead from
peritonitis belly infection
wife's a widow and he never went on his
trip
now when you look at his um obituary you
can look it up online
it says mr rooney died from
complications of a minor medical
procedure wasn't minor for him it killed
him
dick clark the guy who discovered the
jackson 5 and michael jackson the
world's oldest teenager
kind of guy 82 years old goes in for his
physical complains to his doctor he gets
up three or four times a night to take a
pee because
you know you're he's that age eight
years old and doctors well you probably
have a prostate problem and send you
down the hall when i'm done with you got
a urologist to take care of you
neurologist exams yeah you've got a
large prostate here a few lumps and
bumps on it
we can take it out i can put you ahead
of the list i can do it tomorrow morning
11 o'clock
and he says well i didn't reach my age
by going to surgery for everything do
you have a prescription does that
doesn't work
this and this is an outpatient procedure
no big deal you come in 11 o'clock 11 30
we're done
one o'clock in the golf course we do
this all the time no big deal
and and dick clark should have said no
but instead he said okay goes in 11
o'clock the next morning 11 30 is dead
30 000 men in america each year 30 000
men in america each year die within an
hour after the procedure
because when you cut on the prostate
gland either with a knife or a scissors
or stick it with a large biopsy needle
releases a hormone called prostaglandin
which increases your risk of death from
coronary thrombosis
or a thrombotic stroke and he won the
lottery and had both
my favorite though is neil armstrong our
top astronaut
first man walking the moon he personally
saved two doomed
nasa missions save the spacecraft save
the crews but because of his technical
knowledge on
how to communicate with the machinery
and the equipment in a
spacecraft from a computer on earth i
mean
we have more information and more
technology in this little
smartphone than they had on the
spaceships right but he had enough
he could save those two crews he goes in
for his physical eight years old the
doctors came out and said
astronaut armstrong that nasa program
must be wonderful you're 82 years old
you have
perfect health you don't have any
symptoms of any kind your laboratory
world's
work is perfect the other thing you find
one coronary artery is 30
blocked not going to cause angina no
chest pain the odds of you getting a
heart attack from that are very low
but if you wait five or six or eight
years it's a progressive thing it'll get
worse
you could dive going to the hospital
with a heart attack blah blah blah
you're fit now
you should let us put a stint in there
do a bypass you'll never have a heart
attack from that artery he should have
said
no instead he said okay let's do it
three days later he was dead from
complications resulting from
a elective cardiovascular procedure an
unnecessary cardiovascular procedure
we could clean that artery out in just a
couple of weeks there was no
investigation by nasa there was no
investigation by the state
new york state medical society there was
no investigation by the hospital
medical board what if al qaeda would
have kidnapped him cut his head off on
youtube
we'd sent in drones we'd have sent in
seal team number six somebody would have
died
if they killed our top astronaut but if
doctors do it it's okay
okay cholesterol there's not a single
disease that's caused by elevated blood
cholesterol
normal cholesterol for a human being is
220 to 270.
when i get that figure it's from a study
was done
back in the 1950s at the university of
california san francisco
stephen b hulley was the guy who is a
cardiologist and he's also
an epidemiologist he looked at 300 000
people
other three hundred thousand six percent
had blood cholesterols below 200.
and for start of the study for 20 years
he thought they were going to be the
ones to have the fewest
cardiovascular events and and live the
longest well the ones who lived the
longest and didn't have any
cardiovascular events where once had
cholesterol 220 270. he reported that
the general american medical association
you know how many doctors paid attention
to it
zero because they have all these cute
little gals coming from the
pharmaceutical companies and their
little mini skirts
the doctors taking them out to lunch and
they all write prescriptions for
mebacor lipitor zocor and all those core
things right to lower your cholesterol
well i actually did a study when you do
20 000 autopsies and 10 million
chemistries you have a lot of material i
wrote 75 scientific papers
plus that book out of the deal one of my
papers was i compared the coronary
artery plugging
in vegetarians and vegans versus meat
eaters guess who had the worst plugged
arteries
vegans because cholesterol has nothing
to do with it
nothing what plugs your arteries in
inflammation how do you heard the
inflammation thing that's
getting to be new around right well i
said that 1971 it was published in an
international pathology journal
in eight languages it was published in
denmark all went around the world
everybody i had thousands of calls then
nobody did anything
uh he used to hang around 25
pathologists we all go to continue
education together we're kind of buddies
you know
we'd have dinner together and party
together and uh they all laughed at me
said well you must be sniffing glue
everybody knows this cholesterol i said
no no i did all these autopsies
and the ones who are the worst for the
vegans and vegetarians because they stir
fry everything in
coconut oil and olive oil they use a lot
of salad dressings for calories because
they don't get enough calories they
don't have any dense food like
meat and things like that so they're
they're
using all these oils as a source of
calories
trans fatty acids heterocyclic amines
acrylamides cause inflammation
ours respond by plugging well that was
in 1971 here we are february 2012
year and a half ago federal health
officials are adding new safety warnings
about the risk of statin drugs the
widely prescribed group of cholesterol
lowering medications
if you take a stanton drug to lower your
cholesterol every day for 10 years
and you are in a cholesterol restricted
diet every day for 10 years
increase your risk of alzheimer's
disease by 100 you're going to get it
and here's why what is alzheimer's
disease alzheimer's disease is a going
away
of the myelin the white matter of the
brain makes up 75 of your brain weight
it's the insulation material in the
brain
okay when it goes away the naked nerve
fibers tangle up
and they short circuit and you get
alzheimer's disease now i can take a
brain an autopsy and i can never
read the clinical records and i can tell
you by looking at that brain under the
microscope if there's
nerve tangles in there i can tell you
that person had alzheimer's disease just
by looking at slides of the brain i
don't even need to
hear the clinical records because that's
what we call a pathognomonic lesion
it's a lesion that's dropped dead
predictable as gravity that that's it
there's no other option
and then of course that same scenario
will increase your risk of of type 2 bs
by 52
what disease is costing us the most
money in america right now diabetes
our alzheimer's patients are triple
because all the baby boomers come along
who lives on egg beaters and egg white
omelets and boneless skinless chicken
breasts
and oils and margarine instead of butter
cream and lard and tofu and beans
instead of red meat
third world countries don't have
alzheimer's disease because they're
eating meat
in june of that same year 2012 science
is very respectable journal good
cholesterol nuts are beneficial i want
you to email your doctor and say i just
saw something in science news and said
good cholesterol is not so beneficial he
will scream
you know like they do on the on his
emails and go crazy what
that can't be true higher hcl high
density lipoprotein lipo proteins good
cholesterol levels don't reduce heart
attacks that's because
cholesterol has nothing to do with heart
attacks let's say your blood cholesterol
is 200
and 100 of its hdl the good cholesterol
it won't reduce your risk of heart
attacks because cholesterol has nothing
to do with heart attacks
when you lower your cholesterol you have
cholesterol above 300. remember
222.70 is normal you want it to be in
between 220 to 70 300 just means you're
sexier
because you ever hear steroid hormones
testosterone estrogen progesterone
95 percent of cereal hormones is
cholesterol you go on a
cholesterol-restricted diet
you give up eggs there ain't nobody home
anymore
women used to go through menopause when
they're seven years old in three seconds
now women go through menopause in 30
years
they accept prescription drugs that
cause breast cancer you know the
hormones and everything
but they're bio identical that's just
like saying
but the bullet is lead you know it's
copper jacketed
there's not a single medical screening
test that prevents the disease
test that prevents the disease the globe
and mail is the usa today
equivalent in canada i speak a lot up
there probably about
a month and a half if you count all the
days out of each year
screening is not prevention okay
mammograms of course are one of the
the things that women submit to
this was a 30-year study a three-decade
study harvard medical school published
in the general american medical
association excuse me the
new england journal medicine and it was
published last year november 2012
and here's the results said in women
over 40
1.3 million of them over the past three
years
actually had false positives that
amounted to 31 percent
of all women diagnosed with breast
cancer with a mammogram
31 percent were false positives this is
in the new england journal medicine
november 2012.
the worst year was 2008 where they had
70 000 false positives
they cut these women's breasts off they
gave them chemotherapy and radiation
they put them in the cure
calm they know they didn't have it and
these women run around like judas goats
oh you have to go to doctors so and so
he's so good he caught my cancer early
with a mammogram
and once you get a mammogram they said
well mammograms are safe
they have less radiation in a triple a
battery well they came out three months
ago and said one mammogram
has the same amount of radiation as 500
chest x-rays
you know you can do a better job of
self-breast examination even if you're
20 years into menopause
you self-press exam keep a log 15th of
every month at 10 o'clock in the morning
you find something new you find
something tender that didn't used to be
tender
go yourself without the doctor you go to
a
radiology laboratory and you ask for a
high resolution ultrasound no radiation
and it's actually more accurate leave
the doctor out of the loop
here's where the insurance fraud comes
in
a push to prevent colorectal cancer get
your colonoscopic exam
doesn't prevent it oh you had polyps
well pops just means you're eating too
much
deli slices and too much sandwich meats
and too many hot dogs
too much pastrami or pepperoni pizza
okay has nothing to do
polyps don't become cancer psa tests a
federal panel says now
no psa test anymore guys do not do it
why because just like dick clark two
things happen you're gonna be
one of those thirty thousand die within
an hour after the surgery or you're
gonna be one of the two hundred three
hundred thousand to become
permanently impotent and they get ed
permanently and they're incontinent they
just pee all over themselves
it gives new meaning to the term dirty
smelly old man
june 4th 2012 time magazine
health science section skipped the psa
screen experts say psa blood tests for
prostate cancer doesn't save lives
that's because it was never meant to be
a screen for prostate cancer
the most important part of warren
buffett's announcement that he was
diagnosed with prostate cancer
was this paragraph down here richard
amlin the scientist who discovered psa
calls it testing's widespread use a
public health disaster
the guy who invented it calls it a
that's because it doesn't diagnose
prostate cancer and
you can actually through an examination
you can actually make it
go up that's why he calls it richard
applein calls it the guy who invented it
calls it a public health disaster
okay well now we're going to switch to
diet i think you got an idea that
doctors and hospitals are dangerous
pharmaceuticals are dangerous they are
not your first
choice you have to take some
responsibility here okay
this is a harvard study they did in 1990
for males and females in america
came out in 1997 to the public and what
they looked at was life spans
county by county what they're going to
do is find out which county
lived the longest in america i thought
it was kind of clever and then they were
going to find out what medical care what
medical services they had there
they're going to duplicate that and all
the other counties in america and and
upgrade
our average lifespan now from a super
professional standpoint you say well man
that's pretty cool they're thinking
about america but they knew that they
were going to have to increase the
amount of medical care in every other
county right what they didn't plan on
was they found out
that every county in america has the
same medical care you can live under the
bridge and be homeless and illiterate
never worked a day in your life didn't
ever have any insurance you crawl into
an emergency room you will get the same
care that a billionaire gets
not because doctors love you and they're
altruistic they're good christians
they give them this this guy living
under the bridge the same medical care
that a
that a billionaire gets because
insurance pays
what they found out was the longest
lived people in america are in the
purple in the midwest the upper midwest
and upper plains states
the shortest people in america and the
old confederate states
plus cook county chicago and lake county
and gary indiana everything west of the
mississippi river
is an indian reservation it's yellow
orange and red these are the shortest
lived people
the people in the in the purple they
live 25 years longer than the purple
it's not genetic what they did find out
it was how they eat these people in the
purple counties
are all people from scandinavia
norwegians swiss swedes
finnish danish austrians they cook
everything by roasting stewing grilling
how they cook in the old south and in
cook county in lake county
if you never again eat fried foods if
you never again
give your children your grandchildren
your nieces and nephews your fried
chicken
you'll add 25 years to your life if you
don't even give me any vitamins and
minerals if you just don't ever eat
fried foods again
that's what this study this is a harvard
study well 23 years later
23 years later the university of
wisconsin repeated it
dietary habits not hospitals affect how
county's health care rank
they picked pennsylvania because it was
the worst and the best it was good bad
in the ugly
philadelphia county where the city of
philadelphia is in obviously first in
healthcare
we're talking about most doctors per
patient
more households more cat scan machines
more pharmacists more prosthesis i mean
more of everything more massage
therapists right
but had the worse overall health you see
it's not hospitals
with exceptional bleeding emergencies
that's where they shine is bleeding
emergencies but when it comes to
diabetes and highway pressure and heart
disease
they know nothing when it comes to
obesity they know nothing
they don't know anything there all
they're taught to do is prescribe drugs
they don't know
i can't forgive them for that because
they've had a hundred years for somebody
to stand back and say you know
we're killing more people than the enemy
we need to stop what we're doing until
we figure out a better way
why is a dumb farm boy from missouri the
one that's doing it
this guy's been dead for 35 years he's
still killing people fried food causes
trans fatty acids and heterocyclic means
acrylamides they cause cancer there's no
doubt about that
the fda knows that they keep preaching
it everybody keeps going to kentucky
fried chicken
so here's what i urge you to do i urge
you to take your kids your grandkids to
kentucky fried chicken and show them how
to eat there safely because they're
going to go with their friends
you can eat kentucky roasted chicken krc
you could eat their salad bar that's it
nothing else there is safe
same way with mcdonald's i'm on the road
a lot so i eat a lot of mcdonald's but
i'll just have their quarter pounder
with some cheese on it less tomatoes and
onions because they get in eight minutes
and it only cost me three bucks
if i go to friday's the same thing will
cost me eighteen dollars right
uh but i don't eat the bun i don't eat
the mayonnaise i don't eat the salads i
don't eat the dressing and all that kind
of stuff i just have my
burger which is 100 meat and then i put
some cheese on there and i put my
lettuce tomatoes and onions and pickles
i use mustard because all that is
is mustard seeds and vinegar and salt
and water there's nothing else in there
okay and so you can be very selective no
fried foods
i do i do eat their little parfaits
which is a
yogurt with two ounces of yogurt in it
it has four blueberries and a half a
strawberry i know because i do an
autopsy on them every time i eat them
this came out october 2012
just a multiple just one multiple a day
can reduce your risk of cancer
one's one particular mineral we've known
this since 1957 one mineral actually
went to go it went back actually in
1912. one mineral called selenium can
reduce your risk of breast cancer ladies
by 82 percent
if you take 200 micrograms a day any any
woman who didn't have her
ob gyn tell you to take 200 micrograms
of sleep every day should be put in jail
for mass murder
you also if you cook your meat medium
rare instead of well done you reduce
your risk of breast cancer ladies it was
university of south carolina did this
study came out in 1998.
reduce your risk of breast cancer by 462
percent i don't even know what that
means i know what 100 means but what
does 462
mean reduce your risk of 462 percent of
breast cancer if you eat your meat
cooked medium rare rather than
well done because of the heterocyclic
amines and acrylamides that occur when
you burn meat
anybody own a dog anybody own a dog i've
already given you the statistics
we've tripled their lifespan we've
eliminated 900 diseases that we still
have and everybody knows it
you can't give table scraps to a dog
because it messes up all the ratios in
the food
you buy buy food is you know i don't
know what it is now 50 60 cents a can
for a perfect diet perfect nutrition
biochemical nutrition
and triple their lifespan you eliminate
all these diseases the only time you
take the doc the dog
you give them dog food the only time you
take them to the vet is once a year for
a rabies shot because that's the law
you have a dog for 25 years unless
they're really clumsy and stupid and
chase cars and get run over
other stuff like that um you only have
to take your dog for 25 years once a
year to the vet to get a rabies shot
why do we feed our kids their grandkids
food that we know will kill a dog
so as i told you earlier
i started treating my patients like dogs
we came up with a 90 for life program
how long do you need to take it
for life how you need oxygen for life
how long you need water for life
how long do you need god for life how
long you need the 90 cents nutrients for
life
who came up with the 90 essential
nutrients god okay
the garden eden was perfect it had
everything in it now everybody can't go
there there's seven billion people on
earth
we can take the information we already
we actually analyze the salt and we know
it's in the garden of eden
it was the first map quest i don't know
if you didn't realize that the first map
quest is in the old testament
the garden of eden was east of eden
there are four rivers that dump into it
right kishan pishon the tigers and
euphrates
those rivers are still dumping into the
same place that's still the garden of
eden
so i'm going to show you what's in there
there's 90 essential nutrients they're
called essential nutrients ladies and
gentlemen for two reasons number one we
can't do without them
you have to eat them or supplement with
them every day because we can't make
them
we can't make them also if you don't
take them in
any one of them is missing you get
horrible diseases all of which are fatal
some take longer to kill you than others
but they'll all kill you deficiency
diseases
we need 16 minerals two thirds of 90
cents of nutrients are middle so you
know the minerals are important that's
the dust
the green lord made us out of we need 16
vitamins 12 essential amino acids 3
essential fatty acids our food plants
our grains vegetable fruits and nuts
can take carbon dioxide out of the air
use the sun's energy in a process known
as photosynthesis and the chlorophyll in
the green leaves
to lop that o2 off pump it out in the
atmosphere so we can breathe it do you
think that happened by chance
i don't think so i think there's a
overall plan for this
okay so anyway then the the plant takes
the carbon
atoms and makes long carbon chains which
become
fatty acids amino acids and vitamins
okay now
nutritional minerals do not occur in a
uniform blank around the crust of the
earth nutritional minerals occur
in veins like chocolate and chocolate
ice cream because i used to ask my
grandma
those people down the road were hellions
they all lived to be a hundred
they never ate anything solid everything
they consumed was white lightning
they smoked they stayed up all night and
party loud music you'd hear it
three miles away in a flat land in
missouri
and they lived a hundred the pastors
would die at 42 and 48 and 50.
why was that well pastor just happened
to live on a piece of property they only
had 12 minerals in it and the hellions
lived on a piece of property that had
minerals just by dumb luck the pasture
can supplement
can't he now how many can remember going
to your grandma
grandma's house and they had a grandma
and grandpa's house they had a wood
stove anybody remember the wood stove
day somebody may still have a wood stove
over a fireplace
what did everybody do with the wood
ashes every morning did they throw them
in the recycling bin to save the earth
where did the wood ashes go
in the garden they went in the garden
well wood ashes are not ashes somebody
gave them that name
thousands of years ago and they kind of
stuck affectionately but that powder
that's left in the stove and the
fireplace in the fire pit
is actually the minerals that the trees
sucked up out of the ground
when you burn the carbon in the wood the
minerals don't burn they just fall out
as dust
well there's that word dust again okay
into the fireplace for the wood stove or
the fire pit then you take them up and
you throw them you broadcast them out in
the
garden plant minerals aka wood ashes and
the ochre and the sweet potatoes the
onions and the beans and the peas and
the squash and tomatoes and the pumpkins
the corn
and whatever else you're growing out
there suck all those minerals up and
granddaddy did supplement people said
well my granddaddy be 102 and he didn't
supplement we as he did
he put those minerals into the garden
the trees
or the the plants sucked him up and he
ate those plants that he got his
minerals in that fashion
he didn't have in a capsule but he took
those minerals
okay that all ended at three o'clock in
the afternoon monday september 4th 1882.
we know the exact moment because of the
front page story in every newspaper in
the world
at three o'clock in the afternoon monday
september 4th 1882 it all ended
this man here on pearl street on the
bluff overlooking the construction book
brooklyn bridge pulled the switch and
turned on the first commercial electric
generating plant
within 10 years every town and every
city in the industrialized world the
first world country the rich countries
had converted from wood is a universal
fuel
to electricity propane and natural gas
now you tell me how many wood ashes how
many plant minerals are left over in
your home and you fuel it with
electricity propane natural gas zero
and what did you replace it with nothing
and here comes a doctor strutting around
their white coat in their stethoscope
around their neck you don't need to take
them vitamins and minerals they'll just
get expensive here and waste your money
you can get everything you need just by
eating well
you don't need to take them bottoms and
minerals they'll kill you they're very
dangerous you can overdose in them
vitamins minerals
everybody says oh okay you're the one
with the white coat so i i believe you
now this is a cornfield in central
nebraska i want you to look at the
uniformity of those rows the uniformity
of the plants and i'm sure if you look
at the ears of the car and they're all
uniform too
they're the same genetic variety but i
guarantee you just by looking at that
picture
i can tell you that there's enough
magnesium which makes the leaves green
to convert energy from the sunlight
there's enough phosphorus potassium to
drive growth in those fields because if
there wasn't
you'd have bald spots or thin spots so
you know those optimal amounts of those
three minerals that's all plant needs to
make good seeds for the next generation
humans and all vertebrates whether a
hummingbird
a human or an elephant needs 60. plants
only need three do you think farmers put
in 60 no it's too expensive
you wouldn't pay for it and so they only
put in three because that's all it takes
to get the maximum yields
this is my favorite picture there's a
satellite picture from 100 miles up
this is southern california agricultural
and this pacific ocean out here this is
a um arizona over here mexico's down
here 200 miles south
of this salton sea which is a small salt
lake about one tenth
the size of the great salt lake in salt
lake city utah but why don't you see
remember i told you that nutritional
minerals
occur in veins like chocolate and
chocolate ice cream this is what you're
seeing here all these different swirls
and whirls
there are different veins of minerals
and mixtures and minerals different
amounts of each one
so if you were to grow tomatoes in every
square foot that's about 100 square
miles because this picture is taken from
100 miles up
when you grow tomatoes and every square
foot of that 100 square miles down there
could you guarantee without
supplementation that each tomato is
going to give you the exact same amount
and variety of minerals no
i mean you don't have to know anything
but you just look at that picture you
know it's not the same
well in the animal industry we know that
and so the animal industry we put
everything we know that that dog and the
cat and the chicken and the sheep and
the pig and the horse
and the turkey and duck everything that
we're feeding with pellets and
mixtures of grains we put everything we
know they need in it when you look at a
label on the back of a can of dog food
or a bag of dog food or bag of chicken
food or pig feed
guess what the only thing that shows up
on that label is what we put in there
because if they were to analyze each
batch guess what
that can of dog food cost you 500 bucks
the only thing that
label represents is what we put in there
everything else is naturally in there we
consider that value added
and see every morning when you wake up
it's the grace of god you woke up
because the night before when you ate
dinner if you didn't supplement with a
90 cent of nutrients
you don't know if you're going to die
that night by missing one of those
that's how critical it is
eating organic doesn't matter organic
says
less pollutants doesn't say anything
about the nutritional value
of the food they looked at 240 separate
studies
where they looked at the amount of
nutrition minerals and vitamins
in organically grown versus
inorganically grown grains and
vegetables and fruit and guess what
it depends on what role in the field
they're growing in organic doesn't mean
good nutrition necessarily
you still have to supplement that's why
vegans and vegetarians die
long before meat eaters let me tell you
the top 20 longevity cultures on earth
there's not a single vegetarian in the
group they're all meteors
they don't fry anything it's too
expensive to buy the oils they're poor
now this is the core of everything we do
we have 100 cubic miles of this stuff
this is a compost
that has 77 minerals in it it is totally
pollutant free it's the only place in
america that's totally pollutant free
now that's because the road that these
guys are standing on a 3000 foot
elevation
so if the water would raise from the
underground aquifers the underground
rivers bring pollutants into this stuff
it'd be the second flood okay it'd be
bad be like two-thirds of a mile deep
also this cap up here is 25 feet of
marine limestone we know that because
the animal and plant fossils that are in
there are from the oceans
so we know it's been under the oceans
for thousands and thousands of years was
this from the flood i don't know
but certainly has been protected has 77
minerals in it
it looks like coffee grounds we take a
handful of it and this is where we get
our minerals
this is the core of everything we do
nobody else has access to this
we have 25 different ways to get the 90
essential nutrients one of the more
convenient ones we call the healthy
start pack it has three products in it
has 245 nutrients in it including 115
fruits and
and vegetable juices
115 this is not v8 this is v 115
has all 90 essential nutrients and
optical amounts this is designed for
perfect nutrition
for 100 pounds of human flesh for a
month to give this to a 50 pound kid
or a 50 pound [__] from spain it
doesn't matter 50 pounds goes by body
weight
um this this will be good for two months
if you give it to a hundred pound person
give her take 10 pounds that's a month
if you give it to a 200 pound person
give or take
10 pounds is for two weeks if you give
it to a 300 pound person
you ever take 10 pounds or 20 pounds
this is good for 10 days
you have to do it by body weight to get
optimal results okay
i've been doing this twice a day since i
was nine years old
there's a big story that you'll find in
the book dead doctors don't lie or the
cd dead doctors don't lie
okay my wife and i took 10 years
and we read every one of the 720 issues
of the national geographic that were
published over a 60-year period
we found the top 20 longevity cultures
on earth they have 25 common threads
we put all this information in this book
and i found it very interesting
invariably the top 20 longevity cultures
they were all extremely religious
cultures that went to church every
sunday there's not a pagan bunch in the
top
20. i thought that was really good stuff
sorry there's a whole chapter on that
the religious beliefs and how it helps
you
reach 100. anyway we put the top five of
these 25 common threads these people
have first of all
they have five generations living in the
same household conservation of effort
they only have one mortgage for five
generations instead of five mortgages
they have no need for hospice they have
no need for day care
they have no need for education great
great grandma teaches the girls
everything they need to know and great
great grandpa teaches the guys
everything they need to know
so they have no tax burden right
they have no doctors they have no
hospitals or clinics they have no
pharmacies or pharmaceuticals they have
no medicines
great great grandma is the medicine
woman the wise woman who
treats everybody with herbs and plasters
and soaks them in mud and
mineral water and whatever she does
right and everyone in every case
not a single doctor in any of these
places top 20 longevity culture is not a
single first world culture
not a single rich nation in the top 20
longevity cultures and you have to take
note of this
this from the national geographic they
don't have any utilities no roads no
electricity no propane no natural gas or
common fuel is wood
uh-oh and by dumb luck by actual
analysis of the soil by the universities
in the countries these cultures come
from
to get the wood they burn for fuel take
the wood ashes from that wood and put in
their gardens
they have all 60 essential minerals in
it actual dumb luck
see it's not genetic it's just dumb luck
they all get the 90th century nutrients
even though they're from different
ecosystems we show you how they do that
they come from islands and
rainforests and deserts and grassy
plains they come
from mountainsides they come from all
kinds of places but yet they all get the
90th century including the 60th
essential metals from their wood ashes
they have other sources like glacial
milk as they run off from glaciers that
grind up the rocks and things
but they also put their wood ashes and
the wood they burn for fuel grows on
lamb that has more than 60 minerals in
them
they'll live in a calorie-restricted
diet how do you know that calorie
restriction will add years to your life
there is a science that came out in the
1400s the first guy that
that wrote a book on it called the art
of living long was luigi carnero there's
a whole chapter devoted to him and the
calorie restricted diet thing
i'll give an example real quick this
works in every species of animal and
humans okay
no doubt about it what let's take a
three pound male
laboratory rat and let's say he eats two
ounces a day of
ralston print laboratory rat pellets
what i'm going to do is i'm going to
take let's say he'll live
six years on that diet if you do nothing
to me just feed him he'll live six years
but if i take the nutrition the vitamins
minerals it's in those two ounces of
those laboratory rat pellets put them in
one
ounce i've cut the calories in half but
i've doubled nutrition per mouthful
that rat will live to be 12 years of age
monkeys do it sheep do it pigs do it
dogs do it humans do it
he wrote his first book called the art
of living along okay he'd love to be 103
when the doctor said he wouldn't see his
33rd birthday he was 32 years old
and he did it with a calorie-restricted
diet and eating
more wood ashes now these people don't
get any bad stuff
they don't eat fried foods they don't
get any processed meats with nitrates
and nitrites don't drink any carbonated
drinks
not because they wouldn't if that stuff
was there but who's going to build
drive-throughs to sell that kind of
thing there's no roads no cars i mean
why would you build drive-throughs for a
bunch of guys on burros
ain't going to work okay so by default
by default
they're getting their wood ashes or
minerals and by default they're they're
poor they
they only can afford 900 calories a day
these people on the average taking 900
calories a day
americans according to the new england
centenarian study which comes out every
year by harvard medical school they say
americans taking 2 800 to 3 200 calories
every day
these people take in an average of 900.
it's not because they know low calories
good farmers because they're just poor
they can only afford diet their gardens
are as big as this table here they're
posted sam gardens
now they do get 20 times 50 times the
antioxidants we do as actually measured
by orac points orec
is an acronym or abbreviation for oxygen
radical absorbs capacity it tells you
how many free radicals are neutralized
by the antioxidants in a food
this is where the super juices came from
mangosteen goji acai berry pomegranate
juice
patagonian wild blueberries new zealand
blank currants and all these
exotic juices they're very very good
they have high antioxidants
but they're only 125th to the recipe
americans take in 1500
points one thousand five hundred
according to harvard medical school
these people take in twenty thousand
fifty thousand personally i take in
a hundred thousand every day i kind of
hit it hard now this was the last
national geographically red oh yeah it's
may of 2013. look at that
this baby will live 120 and when you
read it
and you read my book immortality you'll
see that they read immortality
because every point they make is taken
chapter by chapter and i love it
it's great because in the western
hemisphere the longest people
in the western hemisphere are the
nikoians from the
peninsula in costa rica central america
they live in the forest they're
uneducated their average lifespan is 90.
they have 40 times 100 hills we do they
have 100 over 250 their population we
have 100
per 10 000. they have 40 times 100
although they don't have doctors and
have clinics they don't have hospitals
no private government insurance
they have grandma and great-grandma and
great-great-grandma what they got
and they have by dumb luck minerals
because they're taking their wood ashes
and putting in their gardens now this
child
from central america is not from black
africa not from white europe or not from
yellow asia
this baby is kind of an indian
from central america these people live
to be 90.
and when they wrote this article is very
it's just beautiful because the last
couple of paragraphs they say well is
drop dead
predictable is gravity these kids will
live to be 120. they're just living
longer and longer longer they're already
living now to be 105 they're going to
live 120.
and we can't tell if it's genetics or
dumb luck
it's dumb luck because they chose to
live there thousands of years ago
so they couldn't find the gene because
there ain't none as they say
okay let's look at billionaires if money
meant something for health and longevity
billionaires should be
as a group they should percentage-wise
not numbers obviously but
percentage-wise
they should have the highest average
lifespan compared to any other
demographic in america and they should
have
more hundred-year-olds if money and
power and you know you know knowing how
to get things
but help you i'd asked him that for many
many years i actually had a cd
that came out with what kills
billionaires look what they called their
article because i kept
telling them and calling them and
calling them they said um
no no no no no in 2004 they did their
own survey
they found that billionaires are killed
by the same unglamorous things to kill
everybody else heart attack stroke
diabetes
obesity cancer suicide because they ate
the same stupid things we do
in 2004 there's never been there had
never been a billionaire lived to be a
hundred
the average lifespan of 78. there was a
lifespan of falling down red wine drunk
in charlotte north carolina living under
the bridge at 75.
they dumpster dive in the you know the
dumpsters behind mcdonald's and live
under the bridge and they live to be 75.
many of them live to be 100 that's
because they don't go to doctors and get
killed
well the the billionaires didn't like
that report and so they said look we
want you to redo that so
forbes magazine did again seven years
later they redid it
and came out in march of 2011 remember
the first one was 2004
they said as a march of 2011 there's
still not been a billionaire lived to be
a hundred
all the statistics from all the things
they looked at in 2004 were exactly the
same statistically except one
one of these subjects was dramatically
different that was the average life span
one did change dramatically it was a
lifespan in nineteen or excuse me in
it was 78 in 2011
66. it dropped 12 years
that's statistically impossible from
seven years to drop 12 years
ain't happening okay that was driven i
mean i could see them losing a week
you can see them losing a month or
something like that but in seven years
time they're not going to lose 12 years
how did that happen so i treat a lot of
billionaires they come to me with
terminal diseases they're told they're
inoperable have less than a year to live
less than six months to live
and i cure them and so i have this big
entourage of billionaires
who who follow what we do they they love
the 90 for life they got their whole
families on and so on
so i call them up and they say look i
need 10 of you
to ask 10 or 15 or 20 of your
billionaire buddies in your country
clubs
one question for me oh yeah well anyway
anything so
i want you to ask them if they've done
anything proactive if they've done
anything different since that
first report came out from forbes in
that said not unlimited 100 they only
lived in average of 78
did they do anything special call me
back weekly i said well that was very
perceptible like yeah
on the average every billionaire spent a
half a million dollars five hundred
thousand dollars
building fitness centers in their house
in their in their workplaces in their
offices and they got these computers
that were voice activated so they could
be rowing
for three hours and given the
instructions for their businesses
and listening to reports and everything
from this computer
exercise is the most dangerous thing you
can voluntarily and get involved if you
do it
incorrectly will kill more people than
anything else
now i'm going to tell you more details a
minute so bear with me
you got to do a little bit more before i
get to that piece so just remember that
exercise is dangerous steve jobs died
10 years before the average billionaire
smart
no doubt about that lots of money no
doubt about that
but he was an unsupplemented vegan he
hired a five-star vegan chef to cook
everything from him they spent lots of
money flew in organic food from
everywhere
they stir-fried it an organic extra
extra extra virgin virgin virgin olive
oil and coconut oil
and then when he got his pancreatic
cancer which is predictable
because of all those heterocyclic amines
and acrylamides and trans fatty acids
from the heated oils
he went to the most well-respected most
highly regarded most published
and most funded cancer research doctor
in america bam he was dead
he died as sure as that doctor shot him
in the head he should have gone to costa
rica
and find the oldest person there and say
i want you to feed me like you're eating
here's some extra money give me what
you're eating
and he'd still be alive today
exercise exercise is a very very
dangerous enterprise
the average lifespan when you take all
professional athletes together all
sports
you add them together the average
lifespan professional athlete is 62.
you take the average lifespan of a
professional football player when you
take out all the suicides
is 51. there has never been with the
exception three black guys from the old
negro baseball league days back in the
1920s or has never
been a professional athlete ever lived
to be a hundred if exercise is so good
how come they don't live to be a hundred
they get paid their only job is to stay
healthy that's their only job when they
get paid
three million dollars a game their whole
responsibility is eat right
supplement right exercise right sleep
avoid all the bad stuff
that's all they're getting paid for is
to stay healthy and perform
they have whole seasons off and they
still get paid every month it's wild
when you think about it
and their average lifespan is 62 and
none of them lived to be 100.
well why is that that's because when you
exercise
you sweat don't you and people love you
and you're sweating in your job you're
working at factories 120 degrees in the
factory you're throwing bales of hay
whatever your work is you're roofing in
the summer time you know uh
that excess stuff it's take plenty of
what
that's what kills you because here's why
that's the obvious question why because
sweat is not water sweat is a soup that
contains all the nutrients in your blood
let's say you're eating 65 72 nutrients
you haven't quite gotten to the 90 yet
the same principle is true for 90 but
the average person isn't taking the 90
yet
so let's say they're getting 65 to 72
nutrients in their food
they're sweating out 65 to 72 nutrients
so here you are let's see this is your
nutritional reserves in your body you're
sweating
and you're drinking water what's
happening your nutritional reserves
that's kind of like replacing a quart
oil every time your engine burns a
quarter oil with a quart of water how
much you do that
by the sixth week your engine wouldn't
be very happy with it so
now let's see here you start getting
break down your acl
ligament you start getting to break down
your cartilage you start getting muscle
cramps
start getting loose teeth high blood
pressure diabetes start gaining some
weight
oh now you got fibromyalgia now you got
lupus now you have a heart attack which
you may or may not survive from
shame on all the fitness guys actually i
have to tell you this quick story
uh i was called to atlanta oh this got
to be 12 years ago
and uh this was to an la fitness center
the manager was one of our associates
one of our distributors and he said doc
i got this whole new crop of people here
they've never heard of it i want you to
give a half hour lecture just on the
just on the sports piece okay it doesn't
have to be the whole thing just on the
sports cities okay so i get
there and there's a group about this
size couple hundred people
in there and um showing my slides on
athletes
and this beautiful girl she had to be 32
years old i mean she's dropped dead
gorgeous
and she's in a thousand dollar silk tutu
you know and all this stuff
and she goes oh doctor wallach and she
just stands up and she's facing the
audience right in front of me
so doctor walk is not violence minerals
it's aerobics and exercise she goes it's
aerobic and exercise
it's aerobics and exercise she goes and
half the people in there 100 of them
were her
customers her clients so they all get
behind all conga dancing out it's all
exercising aerobics it's all exercise
rules it was the most disastrous meeting
i've ever had in my life
i was mortified well three weeks later i
get started getting
hundreds of calls from la we need the
stuff
we need your 90th century we need your
sports drink which we call rebound has a
hundred nutrients and a gatorade has two
so you're 88 sharp with gatorade so
anyway i said why am i getting all these
calls from atlanta georgia
wanting the stuff remember that gal to
disrupt your means well how could i
forget it's worst meeting ever had
last week 32 years old she's on the
treadmill at lunchtime thousand people
in there all watching her she boy she's
doing her thing gorgeous
she drops dead of a heart attack right
there bam and everybody in that center
called me and got on the stuff
it was a very expensive way but you know
she advertised for me so i love her
now the generally american medical
association 1982 the general american
medical association 1982
while running a man's risk of heart
attack death increases by a factor of
700 percent
because it's all honey be sure you drink
plenty of water
out there sweating out your 60 to 70
nutrients you're just replacing with
water you're going to die you're going
to break down
you can't run an engine on six quarts of
water when it should be six quarts of
oil
it's that simple this fellow here ran a
hundred marathons brian maxwell is one
of the top athletes in canada
he's considered a fitness guru heart
attack claims another fitness guru
dies at 51 of a heart attack from
actually the heart attack he died from
was a simple deficiency of a single
mineral i've actually done 1700
autopsies on people that died of that
one type of heart attack
i'm an expert at it not because i'm
bragging it's just nobody else has done
700 autopsies on people that died of
that thing and so
he actually ran a hundred marathons
never came in less than fifth
had fourteen gold medals three the
olympics eleven were in the
the iron man things the world games and
the triathlons
this guy was as fit as a human being can
be he dies at 51 of a heart attack
because he sweat out all his minerals
just drank water in his book you read
his book jim fix the first guy i showed
you that orange book
you look in the index under vitamins and
minerals it says go to page 165 you go
to page 165 it says don't take vitamins
minerals you get everything you need
from your food just run you'll live
longer
and thousands and thousands and
thousands and millions of people listen
to them
why would you follow somebody's advice
who died in 51 and 52 doing what they're
telling you to do
if you lived 150 i'd do it right but
that 51 52 is not a very good
recommendation
this guy here collapsed during a playoff
game
reggie lewis collapsed in a playoff game
with a charlotte harness back in 1993.
28 years old captain of the boston
celtics good looking young fella
great captain he never jumped in the
stands and beat up the paying customers
and stuff like that he was a great
field leader on the court and he's a
great man on the street he's just a good
man 28 years old
and he collapses with a cardiomyopathy
heart attack a simple deficiency of a
single mineral called selenium
and he didn't die he was taken to the
hospital they were able to keep him
alive
so the celtics got a team of 12 of the
top cardiologists from around the world
and while they're arguing amongst
themselves who's going to be the head
cardiologist to determine whether he got
a heart transplant or what they were
going to do with him
and if they did a heart transplant he'd
be the first professional athlete to get
back and play with a heart transplant so
they're kind of excited about that
he dies of a second cardiomy heart
attack two weeks later because nobody
gave him 50 cents worth of selenium
well here comes the real story this is
the story that i want to get to but i
had to precede it with that story
the guy who was going to be the head of
that dream team at cardiology who's
going to take care of reggie lewis was a
guy the name of dr w thomas nessa who is
the head of the
cardiology department of harvard medical
school he ran the boston marathon 20
times himself
he was the cardiologist for the nba he
was a cardiologist for the celtics he
taught
cardiology in the medical school of
course but he also taught it at cme
continued medical education stuff for
doctors and nurses
and this guy was considered the
cardiologist of all cardiologists
a year and a half after reggie died of
that selenium deficiency cardiomyopathy
heart attack
dr nessa dies at the same thing at age
48. now
if i was his family i'd be embarrassed
of tears saying what a wonderful
cardiologist is he dies of a heart
attack at age 48.
he was dumb and dead he was dumb and
dead this guy may have been able to take
your heart out and not lose a drop of
blood and put it into him he may have
been a good seamstress but he didn't
know anything about hearts
because he died of a heart attack and i
thought it was kind of just as he died
in a town in massachusetts called dedham
i mean that should be on his tombstone
died in dedham
now i don't have a doctor i told you i
haven't been to a doctor in 65 years
the only piece of paper my truly the
only piece of paper my health record
is one piece of paper it's my birth
certificate there's nothing else in
there i'm 74 years old
everybody in america be the same way
just think about it just think how
humble the medical system would be if
everybody in america are like me
medically
only go to a doctor once every 74 years
they'd be real humble wouldn't they
please please i'll i'll pay you to come
visit me i'm going to be alone anymore
so let's say just for theory he was my
cardiologist he said okay walk you're 74
years old now you got to watch your
blood pressure why don't you give up
salt
well if he said that to me and i knew
what his future was going to be i would
go around
and i would get every salt shaker in
charlotte i'd leave a buck so they
didn't think i'm stealing them
i built a two foot frame around my bed
and i fill that frame you know
celtic salt celtic salt himalayan salt
sea salt
morton salt every kind of salt pink salt
yellow salt brown salt
everything you can think of i get naked
every night i wiggle around until i'm
sleeping in a cocoon of salt every night
he said that eggs were bad for it
because of cholesterol i'd eat 25 a day
if he said that exercise was good for
you i'd lay on that bed of salt
eating my eggs and i wouldn't even blink
because i wouldn't want to be like him
at age 48
dead dead dead
now following his advice this is what
happens is the gal here renelda pierce
19 years old was chased by every
professional women's basketball team in
the world she was six foot five could do
the air jordan thing she's just a lovely
girl
and she chose to say look i'm gonna take
two years of academics first i'm gonna
go to florida state
make a long story short halfway through
her freshman year she
drops dead during a game at age 19
from a ruptured aneurysm which is caused
by deficiencies of a single mineral
copper
she's drinking gatorade go look and try
and find any copper and gatorade
there's no copper and gatorade there's a
selenium and gatorade they killed that
girl
as sure as they shot her and then they
have the gall to say that she died of a
genetic disease
she died of a simple copper deficiency
she'd taken the 90s she'd still be alive
today
wes leonard there's a play-off at sudden
death playoff
in western michigan for a semi-final
game
make a long story short he catches the
tip off he runs across the court
slam dunks and his team wins sudden
death 54-52
this is him just seconds after he makes
those points his teammates lift him up
three seconds after this picture was
taken he drops dead of a cardiomyopathy
heart attack age 16.
now the medical examiner had a moment
here this is a
this is a national story the medical
examiner had a moment he
they got his name spelled right medical
examiner david start
said the stress leader placed on his
heart through athletics could have
played most of these wiggle words
could have played a role but his death
could not be easily explained it is
explained
it's a deficiency of selenium caused by
sweating and drinking water or gatorade
he had a chance to save every kid in
america there because everybody read
that story
that man should go to jail forever when
he dies the natural cause of his body
should be fed to a rabid dog
that's the meanest thing i can think of
what doctors want to do
as a result of west leonard dying let's
do more
ekgs that's not going to do anything for
nutritional deficiency
it doesn't show up on an ekg this girl
la
dropped dead cardiomyopathy a heart
attack she's she was a
cheerleader girl sweat they need the 90
cents of nutrients too especially if you
know they're going to grow up and have
babies
she died 16 years old somebody needs to
go to jail make a long story short we'll
get on with the next couple of subjects
we'll move on to the diseases
theo ratliff just retired from the nba
14 years his career was over 14 years
ago he had bone bone arthritis on both
knees had cartilage pop off his hip he
caught a passer in the game
fractured his wrist the orthopedic
surgeons at the
atlanta hawks wouldn't sign off on him
so his career was over and
we rebuilt him using our healthy bone
and joint pack and we actually made the
rebound
sports drink for him has a hundred
nutrients in it including selenium and
copper and everything else you need
has a hundred nutrients in it and he
played for 14 more years after the
orthopedic surgeon said
that he wouldn't play he made 140
million dollars after they said his crew
is over
now do you think his wife christina
doesn't love me now next to theo now
she's six foot five herself
so every time i go over there she kind
of hugs me around the head and pants on
my head
she's so sweet rebound
you have somebody you love who's
sweating whether it's work or play or
sports of any age
you give them rebound don't give them
gatorade you'll add 25 years to their
life and they won't drop dead
who needs doctors this came out to
february 2005
special health issue the us news will
report your future physician might not
be a medical doctor you may be better
off
in 1993 i said the average medical
doctor which is done by
looking at 200 obituaries primary care
physicians adding up their age
death divided by 200 got 58. why would
you go to a group of people whose
average
lifespan is 58 to learn how to live 120
as god commanded
they didn't like that so they did their
own studies well wallach lied their
primary care physician family doctor
isn't living 58 like he says we live to
be 56. why were they so eager to publish
that well that's because they were more
interested in showing my statistics were
incorrect
they did show that they were showing
that they died two years earlier so i
will
apologize for giving them two too many
years i want to make a prediction here
deficiency causes white hair and dry
yucky looking skin
he's a classic example of a copper
deficiency aneurysms
here aorta aneurysms so if anybody has
connection with him you need to let him
know he's in trouble
it may make you look professoral but
remember albert einstein died at 64.
ruptured aneurysm he had white hair just
like that okay now the last one in this
section
is my favorite obituary and then i'll
get to these diseases real quick
george francis oldest man in america he
died at 112 in december of 2008.
does his daughter read the newspaper to
him because he was illiterate he lived
out in the swamps louisiana
didn't have any electricity coming out
there propane or natural gas
he used wood for fuel and he lived
through 19 u.s presidents all of whom
the average lifespan of 75.
uh they only had they had one at least
one university degree unless here larger
than they had two and presidents are
cared for not by dumb country doctors
but by very very well-respected medical
guys right
but their absolute man is 56 exactly
half of george's age
when he died he's a black man and when
he died um
at age 112 the reporters asked his
daughter what did your daddy do to live
to be 112 and she said
he broke all the rules of healthy eating
who came up with the rules of healthy
medical doctors who live to be 56
according to their own study
she went on and she said he broke all
the rules of healthy eating with a diet
heavy on dairy eggs and large sandwiches
pig fat cholesterol and saturated fat
i'm going with george because he eats
exactly like all those long-lived top 20
longevity cultures
once you appreciate that the game
changes
now you can't eat fried foods he didn't
eat fried foods everything was steamed
and boiled
he ate like a cajun okay now
we have six diseases to cover real quick
and then i'm done so
we're gonna look at six diseases
obviously we're number one obesity's
we've got to talk about obesity i
promise i would teach you and prove to
you this is a simple mineral deficiency
disease
okay this was predicted following their
directions
they can't be right so why keep
listening if you just do nothing you'll
be better off than you do to listen to
them
just a reminder that's what you're going
to get if you don't change what you're
doing
don't wait for doctors don't wait for
the government because they ain't
changing
according to experts 70 of our kids
under the age of 12 are overweight
40 of our kids under the age of 12 are
obese meaning 30 pounds or more with
their ideal weight
has nothing to do with too much screen
time has nothing to do with a lack of
exercise or eating too much
has nothing to do with any of those it's
a simple nutritional deficiency disease
this is my favorite chart for adult
people who are obese
up until 1980 we were never above 12
obesity it was like
10 12 11 8 9 12 8 9 12
kind of thing kind of like a stock
market but in 80 it jumped up to 15 20
years later doubled
12 years later 2012 went up to 42
percent
this came out in 2006. so i got to move
all this over and put a red bar in here
so that i put the bar in there it's 42
percent now
so what happened here well this one
everything went wrong
doctors said eat more whole grains give
up fat
because carbohydrates and grains only
have
4.5 calories per gram and fats have nine
calories double the calories
but here's the problem you eat a quarter
of a stick of butter you won't be hungry
all day
you eat a bowl of cereal for breakfast a
half hour later you're hungry and you
eat again
and then you get hungry again you eat it
again so you're eating 24 times a day
when you're eating carbohydrates
do we fatten cattle on cream and butter
and eggs no we fatten them on whole
grains oh
what what we fat and cattle and whole
grains you're told to eat whole grains
you're fat oh well there you go
this is not difficult if they were
correct for the past 50 years the chart
should look like that shouldn't it
but instead this is what you got just
like those c diff bacteria in hospitals
following the doctor's directions this
is what you get
this is what you get this is my favorite
now i
i deal a lot with people who weigh 400
600 800 pounds
in that range is what i deal with this
woman was not my patient but she could
have been my page because i deal with a
lot with people like her but she had two
guinness world booker records when it
came to weight
she's the heaviest woman ever weighed uh
they the gizmo booker wreckers would not
believe her weight so they sent their
own technicians and they had a big
flat bed truck come out with their own
scales that they had calibrated and she
weighed
1242 pounds in a seven-year period
between 1987-1994 she lost 736 pounds
after a gastric bypass
and restricting her her calories down to
a thousand calories a day
and then she died because fat is not the
disease fat
fat is the symptom of the disease just
like high blood sugar is not the disease
when you have diabetes it's a symptom of
the disease
you can control your blood sugar you're
still going to die from diabetes
you're going to control your fat you're
still going to die from obesity even
though you've lost some weight
because it's not the fat it's just a
symptom
stop doing what they tell you stop and
save yourselves
okay here's the first real clue this is
not a rare condition this happens a
million times a day
how many ladies when you're pregnant had
cravings that's because the embryo is
stealing nutrients from her faster than
she's taken them in
as the nutrition deficiencies that make
her eat and eat and eat and eat
okay his choices of what she eats i mean
grandma
didn't have ruffles with ridges and
lay's potato chips you just can't eat
one
grandma only had wood ashes and clay out
in the backyard
and so what was she she ate clay out in
the backyard and wood ashes when she had
those cravings
there's no calories in wood ashes and
clay this gal love light bulbs she has a
big story in good morning america in
march of 2011.
she loves wood paper products cardboard
stick sheets rocks dirt she loves diet
coke cans not classic cocaine diet coke
cans
she's the maggots out of shower curds
she loves plastic bottles and toys maybe
that's why they took the
toys out of the happy meal i don't know
so my wife and i came up with another
book that i told you about this one
hell's kitchen
and the subtitle is the cost prevention
cure of obesity it also talks about type
diabetes and metabolic syndrome which
are really all the same disease
these are all the same disease just
different sort of stages of it
um as a cause this is not me that's
alfred hitchcock by the way
okay but this book gives you all the
facts
now here it comes loyola university
chicago medical school
exercise won't cure obesity i mean they
were assaulted by everybody even chuck
norris who sells all those exercises
when she was a tv i mean everybody went
after them
but when they reviewed their daddy said
by golly they're right exercise will
actually make you
heavier if you're not supplementing
properly
so eight months later when it was proved
to the satisfaction of time magazine it
was a cover article
august 2009 myth about exercise won't
make you lose weight because if you're
sweating
you're thinking about that i burned 150
calories in the gym today so i'm going
to
starbucks and i'm going to have an 800
calorie espresso latte mocha polka dough
now here is another clue anybody who
ever worked with horses
okay what do you call a horse cheese on
the fence cribbing very good how do you
get rid of cribbing other than shooting
a horse in the head
you give them minerals you can bone meal
give them trace metal salt block within
three to five days they stop cribbing
so in 1978 the first clinic i bought was
a weight loss clinic
and make a long story short people would
come in every month they'd renew their
prescriptions for a thyroid they redo
the prescription for drugs suppress
their appetite but they never gained any
weight never lost anyway they just stay
the same
they're still 50 100 pounds 200 pounds
overweight so i said you know they're
reminding me of a horse that's crippling
so i began to give them minerals and
started losing two pounds a day this is
what a horse looks like when they're
cripping the horse isn't even there this
is in a
horse and buggy amish farm barn south of
fort wayne india and i was there
to see some muscular dystrophy kids but
they were late the buggies were late so
i went to the bar and being my
veterinary self
and i saw this very typical of um you
see where the heart is cribbing along
that thing too cribbing on the corners
there
reaching over cribbing over there okay
they're reaching up and cribbing along
that
beam so cribbing is munchies munchies
cribbing cribbing munchies munching
cribbing
so if you have cravings and you
take our 94 life program according to
body weight one unit per 100 pounds of
body weight per month
you to use the rebound instead of two
liters of pepsi a day
our monster our gatorade guess what
you'll lose weight
you'll start losing a half a pound a
pound a day you want to go faster
we do have a meal replacer called
thunder effects weight management system
only has 110 calories per meal
i make it with water i like to throw in
a couple of eggs it gets up to about
250 calories with the eggs and
that helps you because then you're only
going to have three or two of those a
day plus a salad
you're cool but well i like to throw in
what we call asap as soon as possible as
soon as possible it's drops you put on
your tongue leave it absorb on your
tongue
and so you do one of those bottles per
month you need to lose 50 pounds or less
you need to lose 51 pounds or more you
take two bottles a month put two
droppers full on your tongue
and i'll give you a couple of examples
this is jerry he had a bread belly he
wasn't a drinker
about a beer belly but he had a bread
belly because his wife judy loved to
make bread he was on our
our 90 essential nutrients and uh but he
didn't gain any weight other than his
belly just he had a
bread belly you have to appreciate red
bellies and beer bellies are the same
thing
because bread and beer is made from the
same stuff they're both made from yeast
and wheat and barley around oats the
only difference is one is fermented and
the other one is baked it's the same
ingredients so you can understand
they get a bread belly in your beer
building all right all you added to his
system
for 45 days was the asap
he lost his red belly in in 45 days okay
well it's 52 pounds now ladies just to
show you women can lose weight too
there's a little brandy
and she's five foot two in this picture
she weighed 158 pounds
and her she had three kids and she
started drinking two these two liter
bottles of pepsi during her present
first pregnant she gained 58 pounds
because she weighed 100 pounds when she
first got pregnant
and she gained 58 pounds she had 58
pounds of fat
okay one third of her body weight her
husband affectionately called her his
chunky monkey that's where i got the
term
and she hated that so when when rebound
came up
she started drinking rebound and she
lost 20 pounds just drinking rebounds
into the pepsi
i mean within a month she lost it was a
21 day one even a month she lost
20 pounds do we put her on the the asap
and she lost another 38 pounds now she's
back down to 100 pounds
now i suspect there'd be more kids in
that family
okay let's talk about alzheimer's
disease there's actually four different
dementias
that americans commonly get number one
the most common one actually is vascular
dementia
the same thing that causes a blocking
the arteries in your heart block the
arteries in your brain it's called
vasture dementia
and you don't get enough oxygen and food
to your brain there's nothing wrong with
your brain there's enough oxygen food
going in there
start forgetting things and it's called
vascular dementia
and then there's korsakov syndrome which
is a deficiency of a single vitamin
this was discovered in the late 1700's
by a japanese naval surgeon
and so we always prepare for that one
there's wernicke course cough it's the
same
deficiency that one vitamin plus ms ms
and multiple sclerosis mixed in with it
and then there's alzheimer's disease
i've seen people with all four dementias
alzheimer's tidal wave is feared that's
because there's 80 million baby boomers
coming along
this came out in 2009. alzheimer's in a
relentless server trajectory it's kind
of like that
obesity chart right and also
the um that is the alzheimer's chart
numbers look particularly grim for baby
boomers because they're on
egg beaters egg white omelets boneless
skinless chicken breasts
and the worst possible thing is they
took the statin drugs to lower their
cholesterol
talk about a perfect storm for making
alzheimer's disease
again a reminder realized in the same
sentence only a doctor could do that
alzheimer's is the only disease amongst
the top six killers in the usa for which
there's no prevention cure treatment
that's all a lie
okay in 1992 the university of
california san diego and the sauk
institute
came out with this study and they said
if you take somebody with advanced
alzheimer's disease you give a high dose
of vitamin e they'll get better
now this isn't some comic book stuff
this is a 10-year study
from the salk institute and the
university of california
san diego medical school so yeah
i i read this into my audio cassette
tape this is part of my audio test set
tape i said vitamin e can ease memory
loss and alzheimer's victims
which means it cannot be genetic
because there's no genetic disease that
you can even help any little bit
by giving a vitamin or mineral so if you
can get some
clinical improvement by giving them one
vitamin that ain't genetic that's simple
stuff that's fourth grade biology
every medical association you know in
every state united states went to their
state attorney generals and had them
send me a demand warrant
making me prove what i was saying was
true otherwise they're going to take my
assets away and put me in jail i don't
know how they put me in jail in 50
states but
cut me up i guess and so
we had to send all 50 states a certified
copy of that newspaper
plus a copy of the cd but they could say
i was just reading that and so that's
the first amendment thing so
all states except arizona and michigan
dropped the charges
had to go do kind of a pre-trial hearing
and everything in
michigan and arizona but the judge threw
it out after they
saw my presentation everything and so
they had to pay my legal fees and
transportation
i love that part okay okay then in 2010
front cover story u.s news world report
america's best nursing homes aging well
obviously
marketing to the baby boomers what
science reveals about aging is your job
killing you your first baby boomers
heart battle but this is why i bought it
seven habits that lower the risk of
alzheimer's disease what does that tell
you it ain't genetic
if you can sleep two more hours a night
if you can walk around the block two
more times if you can eat a banana every
week that you weren't doing
you can read a little bit more read a
book every month because one of the
things they mentioned was read a book
every month
reduce risk of alzheimer's disease it
ain't genetic so right there it says
if it ain't genetic and you get it late
in life that means we can prevent it and
it means we can
get rid of it amen
remember there's four different
dimensions so i like to treat for all
four
well ten years after that first study i
showed you the vitamin e
johns hopkins released a study that they
did in cash counter that c-a-c-h-e not
c a s h but c a c h a valley area utah
and um this was the bottom of a small
sea or lake thousands and thousands of
years ago and the
mountains go all the way around this is
laser flap they didn't have the
bulldozer flat it was just
the bottom of the lakers inland sea so
it's just flat 200 feet of topsoil in
there
and there's no restaurants i mean these
are very very religious mormons that
live in there they're all from a
scottish background
everybody who moved into that valley
came from scotland for some reason
they all converted to mormonism
and they lived and ate and all farmers
and they all ate the food they
wouldn't even go to a restaurant they're
very religious people they're kind of
like the
equivalent to the mormons of the jewish
kosher people are to the jewish people
okay
uh the orthodox jewish people and um
they have uh a supplemental book to
their holy book
okay uh and this holy
book supplement tells them what to eat
what not to eat just like the kosher
jewish people
orthodox jewish people have their stuff
they're not supposed to eat the supposed
stuff they're supposed to eat
right that's what they did here well
johns hopkins how many of you heard of
johns hopkins baltimore
very famous medical school they sent a
whole team of guys out there they found
5 000 people in that valley
over the age of 65 they divided them in
half and they gave
half of them 2500 for 10 years a vitamin
supplement the other half they gave a
dummy pill
double blind randomized study gold study
from one of the top medical schools in
america
they published it in 2004 and i bet your
doctor didn't email you the results
if you didn't you need to fire them i
guarantee you most of you would be
firing your doctors
the first study in 1992 is just vitamin
e
i i was so excited about that i said
they need to get them all 90.
but instead they just added vitamin c to
it we don't want to get too aggressive
here
so just add a vitamin c make a long
story short they said people taking the
vitamin c and e over the 10 years were
less likely to have a diagnosis of
alzheimer's disease in them that didn't
78 reduction in risk by just adding two
vitamins to their diet now i guarantee
it's more complicated than that because
right now as we speak i'm having in fact
i'm going to be meeting with these guys
here
in a couple of weeks they've been doing
an analysis of the soil for me
in that valley because those two
vitamins are a cofactor for some mineral
or minerals in there right now i'm
giving everybody everything so i know
they're getting it all because they're
getting everything
right but i guarantee there's some
minerals in there that are very high
but any rate if you take everything
you're going to get everything right but
just think about you can reduce your
risk by 78 just with supplementation
same people they're homogenous same
cultural background they're all from
scotland they're all farmers they all
live in the same valley they're all the
same religion they all eat the same
things all avoid the same thing that
means like laboratory rats they're about
as homogenous you can get
why did why did um medical school go
there
why did they go there because you can't
in baltimore maryland you can't find two
people who are like let alone five
thousand
that was pretty smart on their part
wasn't it so anytime your doctor says
it's genetic and there's no
way to prevent or cure liar pants on
fire
okay well four years ago i believe it
was
sister he's from greensboro and she was
from charlotte
and she's one of our associates one of
our distributors and she called me four
years ago and said my brother was
diagnosed eight years before she called
me
it said which is 12 years ago now and
said he was diagnosed with alzheimer's
disease and the doctor says genetic and
i might as well get my reservation in
his nursing home right now so i'll be
sure to have a space
the time came blah blah blah and um it's
scaring me and then so i've
took him to neurological clinics i even
went to the medical school here in north
carolina
and um had the head of the department
neurology examine him and he agreed with
the primary care physician that was
alzhere disease
and when she called me four years ago
he had lost his memory completely he's
not able to communicate with grunts or
barks or blinks or
raising a finger or anything he could
not communicate anyway we couldn't tell
if he was
i never saw him it was over the phone
he would lay on the floor and curl up in
a in a fetal position
sorry what i did for him was
say okay look i'm going to treat him for
all four dimensions because we're kind
of late in the game here right i said
well thank you for calling me in early
on the case right
he's in a hospice he's being fed with a
g-tube so you got to get him off the
insurer because insurers made 60
by volume corn oil trans fatty acids the
worst possible thing for a normal brain
let alone anybody with any brain disease
like heart disease ms
lou gehrig's disease or any dimensions
no insurer
okay we need you to get your brother off
of insure
we have that shake we told you about the
slender effects but if we just make it
with water
he's gonna lose weight and what i want
you to do is make it with a heavy
whipping cream because i want to rebuild
his brain
maybe with heavy whipping cream once you
put four eggs in it i want to have two
servings of that a day through the
g-tube
i have to whip it up real fine put
through the g-tube and then i want them
to have
four more eggs and i have a total of 12
eggs a day because i'm calculating how
much cholesterol i'm giving him
rebuild the brain in case he does have
alzheimer's disease right
not cooked but raw then i want him to
have two healthy heart and brain packs
per month but i want him to have four
half doses a day split out during the
day mix it with milk
get it through the g tube that's how you
get the other four eggs in there
then in case it's master dimension i'm
going to take
three of the ultimate daily tablets
three times a day
grind them up put them in with that milk
and the other stuff and put them through
the g-tube
because it actually dilates arteries and
and improves blood flow
then i'm going to take three of our
de-stress capsules three times a day
there's three bottles a month
because it has that one vitamin that's
deficient when you have cortisol
syndrome and murdering cortisol syndrome
he got 28 000 times the minimum daily
requirement of that one
they don't want them to have selenium
and they have nine of our selenium a day
three at breakfast three at lunch three
dinners three bottles a month in case he
has wernicke quartz coffee we got rid of
the plaque in his brain from the ms
then i need him to take 12 of our smart
fx
a day these are dha's and epas which are
the raw materials for the brain to make
neurotransmitters for memory and
cognition problem solving and memory
i'm going to have 12 of those today you
have to puncture a little soft gel
capsule squeeze that
in through the g tube she took a six
month leave of absence
because the technicians and the doctors
at the hospice wouldn't do it
she said i'm going to give him the best
shot i can take six months off of work
and do it
now she calls me a week later i told her
to call me every two weeks and give me
kind of a progress report because this
is
under a controlled situation she
personally would do it every day so i
had faith she was gonna do it
so she calls me on the radio the
producer says doc
there's this lady screaming about her
brother with alzheimer's well it's a
week maybe something terrible has
happened
put her on i'm gonna quote her exactly
so bear with me it's very emotional for
me because i
i want to quote for you okay here we go
so be prepared
and she she said to me quoting her now
he's cured
in one week's time he got dressed and
walked out did not have alzheimer's
disease
alzheimer's sees it take me nine to
twelve months to reverse but
he had korsakoff syndrome which is
curable in a week it's a simple
deficiency of a single vitamin remember
i told you i gave him 28 000 times the
minimum daily requirement that vitamin
because she gave me little signals to
make me think was more likely corsical
syndrome than alzheimer's disease so i
kind of hedged
bet on that one and it worked i do this
a thousand times a year now
very simple it's called corsical
syndrome
the same formula works for parkinson's
ms lou gehrig's disease i have many many
wealthy
uh i mean billionaires that we've
reversed their terminal parkinson's
disease in three months they went from
being
weeks away from death to three months
later perfectly normal okay
parkinson's disease same formula okay
arthritis 95 of arthritis is a simple
mineral deficiency disease
starches osteopenia osteoporosis
osteoarthritis degenerative arthritis
bone to bone arthritis all the same
diseases different degrees of severity
and you know one begets the other as you
go along if you're not solve the problem
we have a healthy bone and joint pack
for that one per hundred pounds of body
weight
and um there's four
ingredients in there so you have to give
a full dose of all the ingredients twice
a day for a 200 pound person
but i like over 150 pounds i like them
to have 15 of the glucogen a day which
are the raw materials to support and
promote
maintenance repair of cartilage
ligaments tendons connective tissue
discs between the vertebrae bone matrix
and bone itself
it's actually a mix of chondroitin
sulfate um
glucosamine sulfate um hyaluronic acid
and collagen
it's all in one capsule this was the
main message in the
dead doctors don't lie audio cassette
tape uh
back in 1992 when that came out
and of course one guy branded me with
that audio cassette tape i never thought
my wildest dreams it would be a big deal
but one guy bought 20 million of them
for a buck a piece
his check cleared it was really weird
he got excited about it so i thought man
this must be something
and since then i've sold 180 million so
you need to kind of change your stories
180 million now they're still going to
store 50 000 a week now 5
of arthritis is rheumatoid arthritis
five percent is rheumatoid arthritis
rheumatoid arthritis is easily curable
in two weeks root arthritis is a simple
infection with a bug called mycoplasma
mycoplasma is the cause of rheumatoid
arthritis it's not autoimmune it's not a
genetic disease
it's not just dumb luck it's not
somebody's put a hex on you
it's just a simple infection it's
curable in two weeks with the
antibody called minocycline like the
little bait fish minnow cycling
take that middle cycling it's gone
you're still gonna have some damage so
it might take you 30 60 90 days
depending on the degree of damage
the healthy bone and joint pack to
regrow everything then you're done with
it
now the doctor will only make three
hundred dollars in office calls if he
cures you with that program
pharmacists might make a few bucks from
the mental cycling prescription
you've heard a middle cyclist remember
the tetracycline family sure if he
treats you first
25 years he makes 750 000 joint
replacements all the side effects of the
drugs you got to treat and
so he has to think for three tenths of a
millisecond am i going to make 300 bucks
or am i going to make 750 000
which way do they all go monopoly no
competition
and insurance pays because it wasn't
insurance you wouldn't mortgage your
house
for 750 000 you just take more aspirin
or you take grandma's herbs
or you take healthy bone and joint pack
of insurance pays well
i've got it managed and you know the
doctor said the insurance will pay for
my
joint replacement so i'm going that
direction i wouldn't want to spend three
dollars a day i need it for my starbucks
coffee
okay this is andy young's living room i
was kind of 40 pounds heavier there but
he canceled his
double knee replacement and uh we
rebuilt his knees in 90 days and he's
been a very good friend of mine ever
since
now this gal here was in a wheelchair
for 10 years before i met her
you recognized some of these folks this
gal here his name is willie barrow
anybody who recognized that name willie
barrow
willie barrel was dr king's accountant
she made sure that not a single penny
was stolen
from the civil rights movement he never
heard of any anything going there was no
mischief with the money with a civil
rights movement and she was the one that
kept control of everything
well i was invited in to be this the
featured speaker is her 87th birthday
party
okay it was at the rainbow push facility
and
ten days she's 87 years old 10 days
after she's on her program she got out
of that wheelchair and walked for the
first time in 10 years
the coming epidemic of arthritis why is
there an epidemic because there's 80
million baby boomers come along and they
followed the doctor's directions they
exercised they drank plenty of water and
didn't take vitamins and minerals
it's a perfect storm for obesity
diabetes arthritis
alzheimer's disease oh yeah be sure to
take the statin drugs
july 2002 the new england journal of
medicine harvard medical school a team
of orthopedic surgeons in harvard
medical school did a meta study on 300
000 people from around the world that
had joint replacement they said
knee surgery hip surgery and shoulder
surgery of arthritis is worthless
give me 90 days give us 90 days if you
have anything along the line
osteopenia osteoporosis osteoarthritis
degenerative arthritis bone of arthritis
no to the surgery suggestion do not do
it orthopedic surgery arthroscopic
surgery replacements or do not do it
give me 90 days first you can always get
the surgery can't you
but i i was personally met a kid who's
seven foot ten he's a high school kid
seven foot ten in chicago
his father's on the suicide watch as we
speak he had a little funny feeling at
the end of his high school days
here on the inside of his right knee and
and
the father says look wait wait the coach
has an end with the orthopedic surgeon
at
the chicago bulls if he looks at you
might
get on that team the kids i don't know i
i don't feel good about that and if i
said well let's talk about it
so he goes in there and the guy says oh
yeah we need to do arthroscopic straight
out scrape the cartilage and everything
will be fine
he gives the kid mrsa they put in a
hyperbaric chamber for
you know two months and gave iv
antibiotics and they wound up cutting
his leg off
now how do you play basketball with one
and a half legs the doctor gets a walk
okay i could have fixed that kid i can't
regrow his leg if he was a salamander i
could
some of you know enough about biology
okay
four years later november 2006 the same
group of doctors from harvard medical
school orthopedic surgeons
published in the general american
medical association said surgery
unnecessary for sciatica low back pain
peripheral neuropathies numbness burning
pain in the feet
bulging disc ruptured discs restless leg
syndrome any of that kind of stuff
all unnecessary give me 90 days we
regrow discs
we fix backs all the time do not get
serious you always get the surgery
that's what andy young said
if you can't fix me i'll just go get the
surgery you know i'm willing to take
you know i've been suffering with this
for 25 years or what's another couple of
months
okay type 2 diabetes is a simple mineral
deficiency
why is there going to be a type 2
diabetes epidemic 80 million baby
boomers come along
exercise drink plenty of water don't
take vitamins and minerals it's a simple
mineral deficiency disease and so we
have what we call the healthy blood
sugar pack you take one healthy blood
sugar pack
per 100 pounds of body weight and take
your fasting blood sugar every morning
before you medicate yourself because you
can have your blood sugar 300
every morning with medication with
injectable insulin
and if you take our program the night
before it could be 68 the next day so
don't medicate yourself without
taking your fancy blood sugar first
i don't get the easy ones i always get
the tough ones
okay this is gangrene of the foot again
with gangrene in the foot i get him with
gangrene in the legs
this fella here his name is buck stefans
came to me was 260 pounds his blood
sugar was 371 with injectable insulin
doctors told him uh he was going to die
within three months he was so bad with
diabetes and all his
side effects complications that whether
they took his feet off or not
he's going to die in three months if
they amputate his feet he's gonna die if
they didn't amputate his feet
so he sold his house moved up to eugene
oregon with his family
so he had spent his last weeks or months
with his family
but he came to a convention of ours
and i told him look you have nothing to
lose your 260 pound guy once on three
healthy bone and
she's got three healthy blood sugar
packs which he did
and in six weeks time his blood sugar
instead of being 371 with injectable
insulin it was in fact
then 68 he's an ex diabetic we gave him
addition to that
we gave him um nine of our ultimate
daily tablets to get circulation down
through that foot we put in our
colloidal silver soaked on cotton balls
in between his toes put a clean cotton
sock on there
change that dressing four times a day
and in two months time that's the same
foot
save both his feet he's perfectly normal
now an ex-diabetic
we can make america diabetes free in
60-90 days playing it safe somebody has
to have the will to do it we have the
ability to do it
give me 90 days first you just keep
taking your antibiotics keep that
gangrene from getting worse and give me
some time
and the odds are i'll be able to fix
this do not get amputations
first without trying something else if
it's not
cholesterol that clogs your arteries
what is it is the inflammation we
already talked about the inflammation
from fried foods processed meats with
nitrates and nitrites oils and in many
cases gluten wheat
around oats okay now this fella here is
a pastor and you may know him
uh he's um uh he's a pastor of a very
big black church
he's 300 pounds in this picture he when
i met him at one o'clock in the morning
in the lobby of a hotel
he brought a letter of introduction from
martin luther king iii
and um martin i worked with martin for a
long time
and he was on the heart transplant list
he actually had a bracelet he says if
this thing starts buzzing the lights
going off just like that thing they give
you
in a restaurant waiting for a table he
says if this thing goes off starts
buzzing the light starts blinking i'm
out of here don't think i'm rude
but i have i'm on the heart transplant
list uh i have congestive heart failure
which is a def
he didn't say this i'm telling you this
he had congestive heart failure which is
a deficiency of a single vitamin
is curable in a couple of weeks
congestive heart failure the most common
cause of heart death in america's
deficiency of a single vitamin is
curable in a couple of weeks
selenium is for the other disease he had
saline is a mineral
and he had it was a hypertrophic
cardiomyopathy heart disease it was a
deficiency of a single mineral selenium
it also had coronary artery disease
which is caused by inflammation eating
that fried
chicken after church every sunday right
he was a big man so he ate a lot of it
and he brought a briefcase kind of this
size and it had
27 prescription drugs in there it was
taken
three of those prescription drugs were
diuretics one of which was lasix
and he couldn't walk from here to that
wall without holding on to the chairs
out loud he want to get a cup of coffee
and he's
while he'd stop every two or three
chairs have to had so much fluid in his
chest and his belly
that tells me immediately that that
those
those diuretics weren't working that's
because he wasn't absorbing him he had a
gluten intolerance
he wasn't absorbing the medicine so you
run into people who say well yeah i can
take a thousand aspirins it doesn't work
but i got this terrible headache it
won't work
they got a gluten intolerance you just
can't absorb them you're not what you
eat you are what you absorb
it's kind of different than the old
adage you are what you eat is really you
are what you absorb
so if you can't absorb it no matter what
you're doing for good it doesn't matter
you have to be able to absorb it so at
any rate
at 27 prescription drugs okay look
i'm going to treat you for all for all
four heart diseases
and i i didn't have at that time this
was six years ago i didn't have the
asap at that time she said look what i
want you to do is take three
of the healthy heart and brain packs per
month you'll be taking
three doses a day of six different
environmental products just from that
that's your basic stuff your body needs
i'm going to have you take
nine of my selenium a day street
breakfast luncheon there's three bottles
a month
i want you to take um 12 of the
ultimate daily talents four four and
four there's two bottles a month because
they're big bottles because we got to
deal with the clogged arteries because
you have coronary artery disease
then i want you to take um the
um the saline was for the cardiomyopathy
heart disease then for the congestive
heart failure
i want you to take what we call the
de-stress capsules
which has that one vitamin is missing
when you have
the congestive heart failure once you
take 12 of those a day
because your primary disease there'll be
three bottles a month
and then you've got to give up the fried
foods and the processed meats and the
nitrates and nitrites the oils and the
gluten the wheat broiling around oats
he's hanging too and that's too
complicated all that stuff and
and diet change his wife is only 100
pounds her name is
you're going to do it she says you're
even do it if you're going to do it not
going to do it i'm going to give it to
you regularly
he said okay i'll do it i've never seen
anybody talk to a pastor like that but
she did it and got away with it
okay she was so angry with him that he
said it was too complicated so
i just will call me every two weeks
that's my deal call me in two weeks
she calls me in a week that friday this
was sunday morning one o'clock she
called me this is god's truth this is a
pastor you could
check she calls me a week later she says
peyton went in
this morning he'd been taking a physical
every friday
for three years because they told him he
had so many complications it had to be a
train wreck in chicago and 500 dead
people for him to get a heart
he's so low in the list and so he said
we got to do a physical on you every
friday
so we have a running knowledge of how
you are so when the heart comes in we
don't want to dine in the ice bucket
we're waiting for a
lab test we're just going to slam the
heart in if it comes
he paid him five thousand dollars cash
every friday for three years twenty
thousand dollars a month cash
you think they weren't using him for an
atm machine they were giggling all the
way to the country club
every friday okay so anyway he goes in
they call his wife say look your husband
didn't turn on his cell phone
we want you to turn around send him back
do not give him anything do not get when
he comes home do not give him anything
turn around send him back give him five
thousand dollars and redo everything
he thinks we think we've mixed all his
data up with somebody else's
so you know what's happening already
right so
he goes in he thought he won the lottery
because now it was his cardiologist
there's another cardiologist
and there's three heart transplant
surgeons he'd met before
he says they got my heart they got my
heart now this is it
they did they did all the tests again
they took him off of all 27 prescription
drugs he took him off the heart
transplant list and deemed him cured
and now he is preaching before he
couldn't preach he had to sit you know
on the stage and then he had an
assistant pastor preach for like five
years because he couldn't preach he
couldn't breathe
he was so full of fluid do not let your
pediatricians give
your kids statin drugs they're talking
about starting at eight years old the
american academy of pediatrics has now
released new guidelines
they want kids to have low-fat milk and
take start cholesterol testing and they
want them to
take stanton drugs do not let them do it
because these kids will not live to be
20 if they start on statin drugs at
8. now this is my favorite
this is the last one on cholesterol then
i can talk about high blood pressure
which is very very good then i'm done
in my favorite cholesterol article
scientific article new england journal
medicine harvard medical school dr
kern was the professor of
clinical medicine at harvard taught
medical students how to be a doctor in
the outpatient clinic
normal cholesterol an 88-year-old man
frank who eats 25 eggs a day
he comes in for his annual physical
there's like a dozen students around dr
kern
and um he said look we are so proud of
you you're 88 years old all your
chemistries are normal i mean it's just
really
interesting and so we want to reward you
we're going to we decided since we get
lots of free samples everything we're
going to give you a free supply
a one year free supply of viagra and he
he stands up he puts his you know picks
his belt up throws his shoulders back
said i don't need none of that viagra
stuff
i'm pretty good in that area so really
all the students are giggling you know
and
because i called dr kern and asked him
he said well the students are really
giggling over that one
and um i said well what makes you so
sure you're in good shape over that and
he says well i eat 25 eggs a day
and you can imagine dr kern a medical
doctor from harvard somebody eating 25
eggs
in their cholesterols in the normal
range he's got to have a heart attack
right so they all run in the lab they
re-run all the blood and sure enough
it's still normal
he comes back out he's sitting down he
says he's patting his brow with his
handkerchief because he's sweating
he's okay tell me why eat 25 eggs a day
so frank stands up again pulls his
belt up throws his shoulder back and
says because it makes me more studly
i are a stud now don't you think about
it
cholesterol makes up 95 of testosterone
if you're on an egg-free diet there
ain't nobody home
you're eating 25 eggs a day
okay high blood pressure quickly is not
a genetic disease
a simple mineral deficiency
salt has nothing to do with highway
pressure if you swell up you get a demon
when you use salt that's because you
have low blood protein eat more eggs get
your protein up
you won't have the swelling after years
of telling healthy people that too much
salt isn't good for them researchers
still don't have solid evidence to back
up the claim
doctors say the stupidest things
constantly like there's no
prevention for alzheimer's disease okay
so you know i'm a farmer
and so you put a salt block out in
pasture for cows and horses and whatnot
is there anybody out there telling a
horse or how they're limited to one lick
a day
no i refuse to believe my patients my
human patients are dumber than a cow
so they just saw your food just salted
salted salted salt to go crazy
bathe in it salted put on your arms put
in your ears put salt everywhere go for
salt
said god says go forth and be as the
salty the earth and he lives forever
doctors say he restricts salt nearly
literally 56. i'm going with god on the
salt thing
so there's two things you need to do in
addition to firing your doctor it starts
with this
during the american medical association
august 2003 they talked about an herb
called dark chocolate not milk chocolate
dark chocolate
that has a substance called flavonols
with lower blood pressure now it doesn't
give you the mineral it will permanently
cure it
but it will lower it like a
pharmaceutical will without the
complications of pharmaceuticals
as flavonols in the dark chocolate okay
so when that came out 2003 we came out
with a liquid dark chocolate called
cocoa jelly plus
it has the flavonols in it plus thousand
of those oreg points in a per ounce they
take two ounces a day we
we're a coffee company but we sell
organic coffee and so we want you to put
an ounce of this twice a day in your cup
of organic coffee make your own mocha
cafe right why give howard all the money
do it yourself
plus you get the flavon also lower your
blood pressure without the complications
of
the um pharmaceuticals we also have
pieces of chocolate each the size of a
pad of butter
they come in boxes of 100 or 20. it's a
little cheaper in boxes of 100 because
there's less packaging
each piece the size of a pad of butter
has the flavonols in it the lower blood
pressure is gluten-free
glycemic friendly so even diabetics can
take it uh two of these will give you 33
000 of those org points so i take six of
these a day
i never take less than six a day so i
get a hundred thousand or points
remember the along the people taking
twenty thousand fifty thousand americans
taken fifteen hundred
i'd taken a hundred thousand i'm gonna
end my presentation with a little
summary here
it goes like this if i were to live to
be
112 nobody would pay attention to it
they say well you know while i can't
claim that's his stuff because people
would be 112 all the time
so i have to live to be 200 i'm i'm
pointing to center field
i'm pointing to center field like babe
ruth right
i'm pointing to center field and i'm
saying i'm going for 200. if i make it
to 179 that will still be better than
112 right
but to get to 179 i got to shoot for 200
so i'm pointing to center field now
remember
here's babe ruth there's two outs two
strikes and the bottom of the ninth
and they're down by three runs he steps
out of the batteries box
you know knocks the mud off his cleats
and he points out the center field
everybody including the pitcher knew
what he was talking about he's going for
a
grand slam so he'd win by one run but
they're down by three runs
that pitcher he was smart he'd just
thrown a ball into the dirt and walked
him
because he could probably handle the
next batter but instead
he's too arrogant and he threw that
pitch and babe rube hit that
grand slam and they won by one run i'm
pointing center field say i'm going for
200.
okay now i'm doing everything right
again and these people live with me they
eat with me
uh we spend a lot of time i give 300
lectures a year they'll be with me for a
couple of days and they pass me off to
somebody else they'll be with me a
couple days they pass me something else
so i eat with a lot of people and they
see me take my stuff every day i do it
twice a day i've been taking the 90
cents of nutrients twice a day since i
was nine
that's why i've been to a doctor in 65
years i don't have any health problems i
have no health problems
okay so the message here is i started
doing it when i was nine
i mean you can start now right i have
four kids
eight grandkids and four great grandkids
and all the stuff before they were
conceived all through their pregnancy
and from the moment they're born
and now i've never been sick none of my
kids my grandkids or my great friends
have ever been sick so the point is if
we all do this basic thing avoid the bad
stuff the fried foods the processed
meats the nitrates and nitrites the oils
the salad dressings the mayonnaise the
cooking oils v canned fish it's fine but
eat impact and water mustard tomato
sauce not oil
use your brains use your heart save your
families
you have to do these things and if we
we can save america but we're going to
have to do it we can't wait on the
doctors to make up their minds
they're going to be a thousand years
behind it took them a thousand years to
give up the idea that disease is caused
by evil spirits
and so it's going to take him a thousand
years to give up the genetics thing even
though that the guy who got the nobel
prize for it said it's not genetics it's
vitamins minerals
okay you're going to have to take the
ball and run with it if you do that we
can save ourselves if you don't do that
you will be burying your children
as it comes down to all right so
we're looking for lots of help i'm not
here just to sell another bottle of
minerals i don't make any money
personally from selling minerals and
things
i do these lectures for free i make my
living from selling books
and so um i i did that purposely so
doctors couldn't take away from the
message well he's selling them vitamins
minerals he'll tell you anything to sell
them bottoms well i don't make anything
from it
i purposely don't so they can't say that
and so we're looking for lots of help
we're in a major growth phase right now
because the medical system is having
troubles of its own
uh the government is in trouble
financially uh
and um the economy is in trouble
financially and so people are coming to
us now who wouldn't have looked at us
before
so not we need lots of help and we give
car bonuses and stock options we give
tax benefits because you own your own
business you can't get these tax
benefits when you're a good employee
you have no tax benefits when you're a
good employee but when you're when you
own your own business even a little ten
dollar business like youngevity
you actually can get you can get back
most of your
withholdings so that for one time a
one-time fee at ten dollars
every year get back thousands of dollars
whoa you don't have to think about that
for three seconds
pretty simple stuff okay so doesn't get
any better than that god bless you all
thank you very much
thank you for viewing this presentation
and remember to contact the person that
sent this to you
for more presentations and books that go
into greater detail
go to doc dockwallockmedia.com and be
well
hey all you dr wallach supporters and
youngevity fans out there
most of you at some point will have come
up against this nutra smart
bashing of dr wallach there are a few
articles that are published specifically
to tarnish dr wallach and his message
and i have actually written this whole
book this was a few years ago i wrote a
full-length book
in rebuttal to these vicious attacks on
dr wallach
i believe every objection that you are
going to encounter in the field
is addressed in this book it's
absolutely a great resource for you to
have as a distributor and if you do ever
have anybody coming up to you saying
i heard what you said about dr wolik and
i was going to look into some of his
vitamins but
you know i came up against this article
on the internet nutrasmart article is
probably the one they read
so it's a great deal guys i put it up
very cheap it's just
another tool in our toolbox and the
amazon link is in the description of
this video
make sure to check out our food youtube
channel called notice foods
this is 100 dr wallock approved
and the chef that is preparing the food
here and teaching you how to
follow dr wallach's food guidelines and
dr glidden's food guidelines
he is a industry professional over 22
years experience and a college diploma
to back it up
and we do have experienced cooks and
bakers as well working on content for
the youtube channel notice foods
and the instagram channel known as 100
gluten free
oil free all the stuff about burning
fats and all of the rules
that you would need to know or follow
we're here to teach it to you here
as well as give you tons of ideas for
recipes
individual dishes and meals of course in
the near future we do have a cookbook
coming out stay tuned for it
and if you'd like to talk to us directly
you can call us actually you can call
judy
she's downriver detroit you can call
from anywhere in the u.s
canada mexico uk australia
new zealand any other country you want
to email us or send us a dm on whatever
app that you want to contact us on
instagram is super convenient for us and
that's for any sales or product
information in those countries
or any distributor information
[Music]
you